...
Wir können...!
Wir können...
ah ja leute ich bin auch mal wieder am start stellt euch das mal vor richtig voll gefressen
gerade ich habe ich habe burger bestellt ich habe drei burger gefressen so viel zum thema abnehmen
moin ist hier gerade mal was schreiben und ich gerade sehe
falls dich das interessiert aber ich gehe mal davon aus
zweiste bescheid
ja wo genau ist offiziell ja geheim aber dir kann ich das ja erzählen
so also leute ich bin auch mal wieder am start richtig voll gefressen ich habe
gerade mittag gegessen 20 minuten lang drei burger pommes frites grautsalat ganz wichtig
grautsalat ja das bisschen das ist ein bisschen gesund ist wenigstens
so also wo sind wir stehen geblieben was ist das hier ist saatkartoffel fragt was
darf ich kurz was in die runde das immer was in die runde fragen ob ich das natürlich beantworte
ist was anderes gerade sachen die chain law fragt und dann fünf mal aus rufe zeichen frage
macht die beantworte ich aus prinzip nicht mehr so wenn ihr einen lebenslauf schreibt
wie stellt ihr eure it kenntnisse da direkt mit einer projectliste die zu den einzelnen
githab projekten verlinkt ist oder lasst ihr das komplett raus und führt nur berufliche
bildung berufserfahrung bei betrieben zertifikan auf also ich kann dir sagen wie ich das
gemacht habe ich habe ich habe keine ahnung ob das eine gute sache sie meint es hat jetzt
funktioniert ja
so ich kann dir erzählen ich kann dir erzählen wie ich das gemacht habe und zwar ich habe
das folgendermaßen gemacht ich habe ich habe lebenslauf gebaut da ist im prinzip so die
die station drin es ist ja nicht so als gäbe es bei mir da sonderlich viel ja ich habe
also ich habe gar keine it kenntnis in lebenslauf reingeschrieben ich habe reingeschrieben
schule ausbildung zivildienst was habe ich denn noch reingeschrieben mal schule zivildienst
ausbildung was habe ich da vorher noch reingeschrieben ich habe zwei sachen vorher ach keine ahnung
war ich aus dem kopf nicht mehr und dann halt ausbildung was ich nach der ausbildung gemacht
habe dann den arbeitgeberwechsel und jetzt bis jetzt so da habe ich drunter geschrieben
ganz grob für was man zuständig war so nach dem motto also bei dem einen habe ich habe
ich geschrieben 24 7 kann ich hoch hoch verflich ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wie ich es geschrieben
habe ich kann jetzt auch gar nicht nachgucken was die lebenslauf jetzt nicht aufmachen kann
ich habe sinngemäß so was reingeschrieben wie hoch verfügbarer 24 7 betrieb eine komplexe
linux umgebung und so dinge ich habe das dann nur ganz abstrakt hingeschrieben und dann
habe ich dazu eine liste gepackt dreiseitige liste mit skills da habe ich wirklich das
haben wir uns ja zusammen im stream überlegt da habe ich wirklich alles reingeschrieben
was mir so eingefallen ist wir haben irgendwo hier haben wir auch die liste allerdings ist
das nur die nur die vorläufige das nur die vorläufige liste da ein paar sachen habe
ich noch geändert und angepasst das ist nicht eins zu eins die liste die ich in meine bewerbung
reingeschrieben habe aber so ungefähr sieht die sieht immer noch aus
also manche sachen die wir hier rein als miemfaktor im stream reingeschrieben haben zum beispiel
kobold habe ich wieder rausgenommen weil niemand kauft mehr ab ich habe ahnung von kobold dabei
habe ich wahrscheinlich wirklich mehr ahnung als 99,999 prozent der weltbevölkerung von
kobold das heißt aber nichts das heißt immer noch ich habe wirklich sinnvoll programmieren
kann ich war das einzige was wir im stream gemacht haben ist kobold glaube ich mal eine
datei eingelesen und und hallo hallo max output oder sowas nix großartiges so der rest ist
noch mehr oder weniger gleich also wie gesagt kobold habe ich rausgenommen andere sachen
habe ich zusammengefasst ich habe nämlich glaube ich hier habe ich irgendwas noch zusammengefasst
best scripting habe ich glaube ich rausgelassen habe irgendwie üblichen tools nur noch geschrieben
und habe dann irgendwo anders noch was gelöscht ich weiß nicht mehr irgendwie das ist das
ist runder das ist runder klang ja damit machen wir übrigens heute was auf google cloud warum
google cloud weil ich gehört habe dass mein neuer arbeitgeber viel google cloud verwendet
und ich zwar mit google cloud schon was gemacht habe vor allem muss ich sagen mit der google
maps api die anderen sachen die ich sonst in google cloud gemacht habe ich habe einen
manage kubernetes cluster zusammen geklickt die haben ja zwei varianten bei google cloud
für sowas zusammen zu klicken einmal so ein super simplifiziertes ding da drückst du
zwei dreimal auf auf weiter gibst die region an und irgendwie noch zwei sachen dann ist
das da oder du kannst es besser custom als ich habe mal durchgeklickt ja fertig und ich
habe vor allem angelegt so was also ich bin nämlich da prinzipiell zurecht aber ich habe
noch nicht so extrem viel gemacht mit google cloud mit polumi habe ich auch noch nicht
so viel gemacht damit habe ich auch ein bisschen rumgebastelt habe da schon mal kisten aufgebaut
bei hetzer zum beispiel und laut balancer firewalls und was man halt so braucht dass
man was betreiben kann aber das ist jetzt auch nicht so dass ich sagen würde ich habe
von polumi so richtig ultra krass plan genauso wie von google cloud deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht wir gucken uns das mal an polumi verwenden die übrigens nicht die verwenden auch terraform
so wie jeder der irgendwie halbwegs normal im kopf ist wobei ich polumi vom ansatz her
nicht schlecht finde sage ich gleich was zu erstmal erstmal wir können erstmal eine
runde schwätzen ich muss mich erstmal wieder an streamen gewöhnen ich habe jetzt keine
ahnung eine woche oder so nicht richtig gestreamt der daufach stream zählt nicht kann man das
hier mal seriously es gibt es ein pop-up nur um es zu quitten das ist ja fast wie früher
start to quit oder wie wie war das drücke start zum herunterfahren oder oder was stand
aber bin aus 95 noch press start to press start to stop oder irgendwie sowas in der
richtung du kannst es als fortbildung eintragen ja start kartoffel ich hoffe es hat jetzt was
gebracht also kann ich nur sagen wie ich das wie ich das gemacht habe also ok ich kann
ja noch sagen wie es ein kollege gemacht hat wir haben uns ja quasi zusammen beworben
dort habe ich ja erzählt bei dem sieht er der hat keine skillliste gemacht dafür hat
er drei seiten lebenslauf ich habe nur eine seite lebenslauf so ganz grob mit ein paar
dingen dafür dreiseitige skillliste und er hat einen dreiseitigen lebenslauf und er
hat auf der letzten seite von seinem lebenslauf auch alle möglichen kurse und zertifikate
drauf ja von von den azure basics bis dass er in pp zertifikat hat in den vmw ding und
sonstige geschichten hat alles auf der dritten seite drauf es ist wahrscheinlich geschmackssache
ich kann euch nicht sagen ich bin ja kein personaler ich kann euch das nicht sagen wie das jetzt
besonders gut ankommt oder wie das besonders gut schlecht ankommt letztendlich ist es wahrscheinlich
auch ein bisschen individuell je nachdem also von euch und was weiß ich was der jeweilige
personal personaler für den geschmack hat insgesamt ist denke ich einfach wichtig dass
ihr gut da steht ich meine so bescheuert es klingt aber ich meine es ist letztendlich
das wichtigste in der bewerbung dass ihr gut da steht und wie ihr das jetzt macht es muss
es muss irgendwie zu euch passen ihr müsst es ja im zweifelsfall wenn ihr eingeladen
werdet auch soweit vertreten können und beziehungsweise irgendwie dass das das untermauern können
also wenn ihr da jetzt random generator skill ist random generator lebenslauf macht und
die fragen euch was zum dritten punkt und ihr habt vielleicht mal in einem heise artikel
vor drei jahren zwei wörter darüber gelesen erbringt das wahrscheinlich auch nicht so
viel deswegen habe ich aber mir in die skill ist auch wirklich bloß sachen reingeschrieben
mit denen ich schon mal was gemacht habe und ein bisschen mehr als das was ich mit kobold
schon gemacht habe deswegen habe ich kobold wieder rausgeschmissen und sie haben aber
auch gesagt es ist sehr sehr vielfältig in allen gebieten gesagt ja ich weiß ich habe
extra alles reingeschrieben es ist ja auch so ich meine wenn irgendjemand sagt das stimmt
nicht dass ich gucke in stream archiv wir haben über fast alles was hier drinnen steht
schon schon streams gemacht und und in streams verwendet ok ich glaube power shell nicht
ich glaube in power shell haben wir im stream noch nichts gemacht aber ich habe sogar vor
jahren mal ein power shell buch gelesen damit bin ich qualifizierte als die meisten anderen
und ich habe in power shell auch schon sachen automatisiert und geskriptet ich persönlich
bin ja der meinung power shell also wenn man jetzt die frage sagen wir zsh bash versus
power shell stellt sich meiner meinung nach gar nicht power shell ist eine richtige mist
shell wenn es um interaktives tägliches arbeiten geht dafür ist für automatisierungszwecke
und scripting zwecke power shell finde ich deutlich deutlich besser als bash ich meine
ihr wisst ich bin bash fan beziehungsweise bash script fern wir haben hier dinger schon
in bash geskriptet wo alle anderen gesagt haben macht doch mal hier pyson zwei zeiler
oder sowas in der richtung ob sie nein nein nein nein wir machen das in bash und das
klappt auch irgendwie power shell ist deutlich durchdachter zum scripten du hast du merkst
power shell an dass du nicht irgendwie 180 jahre boomer legacy sachen drinne hast ja
weil die bash syntax war seriously gibt es irgendjemand hier der sagt er hat die bash
syntax verstanden na klar die basics die haben wir alle die ein bisschen was gemacht haben
schon verstanden aber in den details ist das teil war es ist wirklich nicht durch durch
zu blicken ich mein wie ist die array syntax warum gibt es dollar add dollar sternchen dollar
dollar und solche sachen machen alle unterschiedliche sachen wie greife ich auf das erste element
in dem bash array zu wie mache ich string interpolation gescheit in bash und schneide
den letzten character aber es geht alles ist von der syntax ja halt richtig beschissen das
ist in power shell besser und das peipen zwischen den kommandos ist in power shell
auch besser also wenn ich wenn ich wenn ich mal kurz meine linux vm an bevor ich hier
lange rumschwätz also was ja in bash relativ ich sag jetzt mal bash stellvertretend für
alle linux shells fisch mal außen vor die machen wishell basic style eigenen krempel
aber bash zettas haar was gibt es denn da sonst noch so alles dürfte eigentlich die
verbreitetsten sein ja aber wir können bei der gelegenheit gerade mal updaten ja also
wo ich gerade dabei war ich schweiß mal kurz das update an schadet nix ja mach mal update
so genau also was ja bei bash ganz gut geht ich kann jetzt beispielsweise hier ein kommando
nehmen echo 123 123 ausgeben und danach kann ich das peipen in ein anderes kommando und
kann danach kratten zum beispiel jetzt war relativ sinnlos was ich da gemacht habe weil
der output das gleiche ist aber ok also sprich ich kann den output hier von nehmen und weitergeben
eine input von dem programm das ist allerdings hier an der stelle es ist immer plain text
das ist in power shell nicht so in power shell sind das hier was du von einem programm zum
anderen programm weiter gibst oder vom einen kommand zum anderen kommand weiter gibst sind
komplette dot dot net objekte also du kannst dann beispielsweise hier in dem krepp auf
ja eigenschaften zugreifen von diesem objekt was das echo ausgegeben hat zum beispiel könnte
das dann haben keine ahnung objekt title description name runtime was auch immer und das könnte
sich dann hier drinnen wieder verwenden das geht in bash nicht deswegen ist power shell
zum scripten und zum automatisieren wirklich cool weil das unter der haube im prinzip ja
eigentlich dotnet basierte scripting umgebung ist das geht in bash nicht dafür ist das
interaktive arbeiten finde ich so mit bash und zsr viel viel angenehmer so genau ja
weiß ich bin ich jetzt eigentlich darauf gekommen starbucks danke für den sub steinadler 5 massive
subscription dazu kann ich nur sagen oder ich könnte jetzt ja auch mein weepkeks nehmen
so also weiter im text ok ja heute wird es ich weiß ich wie high IQs heute wird weil
ich hab damit selbst jetzt noch nicht so viel gemacht weil mit der kombination nicht was
das ist ist der eier ja ja ja den account gibt es immer noch leider habe ich den zugang
nicht mehr so nice sagt bin nach drei jahren home office wieder im büro am arbeiten mega
cringe ja da gebe ich dir recht also das war bei mir auch anfang des jahres so beziehungsweise
das ganze ging ja schon ende letzten jahres los anfang des jahres ne moment was erzähle
ich denn blödsinn stimmt stimmt gar nicht mitte des jahres mitte des jahres ging das
ganze ja schon los ich habe mich da noch ein bisschen vorgedrückt mittlerweile ist es ja
dort wo ich arbeite so dass die das denen was vorschwebt zwischen 50 prozent anwesenheit
und mehr was für mich ja auch habe ich ja schon oft genug gesagt der entscheidende grund
schlechthin war gerade auch im ausblick wie sich das ganze entwickelt ja wahrscheinlich
wird es dann noch mehr und dass ich da sowohl gehaltstechnisch nicht viel getan hat und auch
was mir halt wirklich auf den keks gegangen ist das ständige hin und her was home office
angeht zuerst sich super modern gegeben super tolle home office regelung mit dem betriebsrat
extra extra wie heißt das betriebsvereinbarung alles ganz toll und kann man jetzt aus ausmachen
mit seinem chef habe ich damals mit meinem chef ausgemacht alles gut bis man dann irgendwie
zwei monate später auf die idee gekommen ist ach ne ne das gilt jetzt doch nicht mehr und
wir hatten leute die sind umgezogen ja also sprich es gab diese vereinbarung man hat ihnen
gesagt ja passt home office kein problem und die sind wirklich umgezogen danach die sind
quasi aus frankfurt weg bisschen dahin wo es billiger ist wo die sich vielleicht auch
eine wohnung ein haus irgendwie sonst was leisten konnten oder hat man ihnen gesagt
ach nee wir haben es uns doch wieder anders überlegt jetzt kommt mal gefälligst wieder
jeden tag oder jeden zweiten oder oder 50 prozent wie es auch immer bei euch ist mal
mal her und dass die leute sind natürlich auch jetzt richtig im arsch und sagen sich
nö dann tue ich mir was anderes und das hin und her das war für mich damals der ausschlaggebende
punkt dass ich gesagt habe ich muss mich mal nach was anderem umgucken richtige dick move
genau anders kann man das nicht nennen was ich halt was ich bei uns halt auch lustig
finde auf der ersten bei der ersten sache haben sich halt mega gefeiert so wie modern
man ist und letztens war irgendwie so eine veranstaltung und daraufhin wurden natürlich
dort auch die der oberen oberen manager die dort waren in so einer fragerunde auf das
thema homeoffice angesprochen und die sind überhaupt nicht richtig drauf eingegangen
das einzige was sie gesagt haben da musste ich muss ich mir wirkliches lachen verkneif
was heißt verkneifen ich hab daheim gesessen ich muss mich nicht verkleidet habe ich mir
auch in kopf gegriffen haben sie gesagt nein nein nein das wäre überhaupt nicht so er
hatte jetzt schon bewerber bei ihm sitzen und die bewerber haben gesagt sie wollen explizit
dorthin weil wir so eine tolle bürokultur haben da hab ich mir auch gedacht ja alles klar wie
willst du das erzählen mann wie willst du das erzählen aber ganz davon abgesehen mal ganz
davon abgesehen bewerber wenn die den job brauchen und haben wollen die erzählen den doch alles
stelle ich mal vor stelle euch mal vor ihr seid bewerber wollt den job haben braucht vielleicht
geld wollt das wirklich vielleicht unbedingt mal aus irgendwelchen gründen aus irgendwelchen
gründen wollt ihr den job haben und es erzählt ihr dann einer wir haben hier eine ganz tolle
office kultur und homeoffice will ja bei uns gar keiner machen und wir sind alle so dicke
und wir freuen uns alle dass wir vor Ort sein dürfen und wie sehen sie das ich mein soll
der typ wenn er den job wirklich haben will sagen oh nee da habe ich gar keinen bock drauf also
eure office kultur juckt mich mal gar nicht ich will daheim sitzen sagt er bestimmt nicht
der sagt dann auch ja diese office kultur ist ganz besonders toll deswegen habe ich mir bei euch
beworben oder so was so kommt das dann halt zustande blödsinn blödsinn mich stört das ja auch im
prinzip gar nicht ich sag auch nicht dass es unsinnig ist es hat durchaus seine vorteile manchmal vor
ort zu sein ist gar keine frage ja für mich als homeoffice sowohl produktivitäts vorteile als auch
dass es mir besser geht also ich schaff mehr und mir geht es besser bei also kombination ist
eigentlich für alle seiten das beste ist das beste für den arbeitgeber ist das beste für mich und
es ist das beste für euch weil ich insgesamt entspannter ausgeruhter und wacher bin um content
zu produzieren also ist eigentlich für alle das beste für euch also chat ihr seid gemeint ja für
meinen arbeitgeber und für mich also eigentlich ist homeoffice das beste aber gut wenn sie nicht
wollen es ist ja alles schön und gut ist ja auch letztendlich ihr gutes recht das zu sagen aber
genauso wenig wie ich sie zwingen kann können sie mich zwingen und das war letztendlich ganz gut
dass es so gekommen ist ich habe da ich habe da richtig richtig ärger gekriegt mit meinem
chef einmal also mit meinem neuen chef habe ich aber richtig ärger gekriegt weil es hieß jetzt
rückt man alle wieder zwei tage an zwei tage hingekommen und hat mir gedacht er wird schon
kein großartig interessieren weil alle haben sie immer gesagt er super arbeit alles ganz toll und
dann hat er sich einmal richtig aufgeregt weil sein chef gefragt hat wie sieht es bei euch aus
ja und da habe ich richtig ärger gekriegt und das war der punkt wo ich gesagt habe okay hier
bleibe ich nicht mehr der konnte da im prinzip auch nichts für ja wir haben uns dann wir haben uns
darauf geeinigt ja ich gucke mir das an und ich habe ihm da aber auch gesagt also ich bin schon
am gucken und also das jahr werde ich wahrscheinlich dann hier also das war es dann wahrscheinlich ja
und ist dann im endeffekt auch so gekommen aber es war gut es war eigentlich gut dass das so
gekommen ist jetzt im nachhinein weil ihr wisst ja ich bin was sowas angeht ziemlich faul also
wenn ich mir wenn es mir irgendwo ganz gut gefällt und ich mit allem drum herum zufrieden bin suche
ich nicht permanent nach neuen jobs oder so warum soll ich das machen ich wusste klar ich habe
mir ich habe mir die letzten jahre über ja schon manche angebote angeguckt wir haben uns
zusammenstellen anzeigen angeguckt ja ich habe mit leuten geredet hier von euch im discord von
ex-kollegen die ich noch kenne was es woanders gibt und was man da verdient teilweise dass ich
wusste dass sowohl das gehalt da jetzt nicht der super wahnsinn ist als auch die sachen drum
rum nicht so geil sind aber es hat mich noch nicht genug gestört aber als diese home office thematik
dazu gekommen ist habe ich gesagt ok das will ich echt nicht mehr ich habe jetzt drei jahre gesehen
wie wunderbar das funktioniert und dass das für mich besser ist und für die firma besser ist das
sehe ich nicht ein und deswegen ist ganz gut dass es so gekommen ist deswegen habe ich jetzt
angefangen rumzugucken und es war ja wirklich easy mode muss man dazu sagen ja also die die jobs ich
hatte insgesamt jetzt vier vier bewerbung erste erste also gut ich hatte noch mehr anfragen aber
ein paar sachen ist es da gar nicht bis zum bewerbung hinschicken gekommen die die lassen
das lassen wir weg also erste sache hat sich tatsächlich jemand hier gemeldet nach dem stream
per mail hat gemeint hier max ich habe gesehen und wie sieht es wir suchen leute die fand ich auch
nicht schlecht muss ich sagen ich habe schon wieder vergessen wie die wie die hieß das war so eine das
das war das was hatte was mit börse zu tun genau stimmt ich weiß wieder und das da wollte ich auch
mit dem tag mal probe arbeiten mir das angucken hat er leider nicht funktioniert weil erst hatte
er koch erst hatte ich korona dann hatte dort mein ansprechpartner korona und als es dann wieder
soweit war haben sie festgestellt na börse technisch lief es ja dieses jahr nicht so gut sie
wollen erst mal warten mit neueinstellungen wie wie sich das alles wirtschaftlich entwickelt
ok dann dann ich kann wir nichts machen und ob sie sich nächstes jahr noch mal melden dürfen klar
kann man machen weiß nicht ob es dann noch aktuell ist ja so dann hat ich noch was anderes da die
waren aber mega langsam die sind so langsam die sind so langsam gewesen dass ich bis heute von
denen obwohl sie es eigentlich ganz toll fanden noch nichts konkret das gehört habe also die
sind richtig langsam mag mag auch an der branche liegen da ist man vielleicht ein bisschen langsamer
die sind richtig langsam so dann hatte ich in würzburg die den termin das habe ich ja über
ein ex-kollege von dort wo ich jetzt arbeite der ist jetzt dort in würzburg habe ich das habe ich
das gefunden die haben mich ja angeschrieben wie es ausschaut sie suchen noch leute das war dann
dort als als senior ich kann es mir nicht merken es war entweder also leute ich kann mir aus dem
kopf nicht merken welche stelle was genau war entweder ist es denkt denkt euch denkt euch dazu entweder
ist es senior devops engineer senior system administrator oder senior senior linux engineer
eins von denen drei war es überall letztendlich macht unterm strich aber vom aufgabenbereich
eigentlich kein unterschied und da bin ich hingefahren also erstmal remote erst mal remote
gespräche gemacht lief ganz gut da habe ich auch das video darüber gemacht dann war ich vor ort
habe mit den kollegen dort was mit den theoretischen zukünftigen kollegen noch mal geredet und die
haben ich ein bisschen befragt ich habe ein bisschen gefragt also ich fand die leute wirklich sehr
nett dort ja auch die personal abteilung meinen theoretischen theoretischen chef dort die leute
dort also wirklich super geschichte war auch gemerkt die halten da zusammen und ein bisschen gegen
die entwickler geflammt finde ich immer ganz lustig weil die entwickler flamen eigentlich immer über
operating administrationen und sonst was und die anderen flamen immer über entwickler das ist
normal ja also es ist dann quasi so entwickler kommen dann so um die ecke so nach dem motto
kann auch nicht so schwer sein da mal eine neue kiste zu installieren und admins kommen dann um
die ecke und sagen kann auch nicht so schwierig sein mal gescheite logs raus zu raus zu printen
oder es ist immer so ein bisschen gebäsche untereinander zwischen zwischen administration
entwicklung change management betrieb und was sie alles ist normal ja finde ich eigentlich ganz
lustig so mit denen war ich mir schon so weit eigentlich dass ich von denen sogar einen vertrag
geschickt bekommen habe also sprich ich hatte von denen vertrag erst mal in der post und also in
der in der e-mail in der inbox in per mail hatte ich von denen den vertrag schon zugeschickt
bekommen und ich habe darauf gewartet dass der vertrag per post kommt eigentlich war ich mit
denen schon einig es gab ein bisschen mehr kohle und es gab viel homeoffice das war war mir wichtig
viel homeoffice ein bisschen mehr kohle gut ich war in würzburg was aber nicht schlimmes was ich
will ich weil ab und zu da mal hinfahren so einmal im monat wäre alles ok gewesen gut dann
war ich war ich hatte die sache eigentlich schon abgehakt ich habe gesagt ok ich dachte mir so
ey wenn der vertrag kommt und dann schreibe ich das kündige und fertig so dann kam aber während
der vertrag von den anderen aus würzburg schon bei mir per email da war aber noch nicht per post
kam lustigerweise noch jemand den ich von früher kenne hat mir messen message geschrieben auf dem
handy max wir suchen noch ein paar neue leute hast du nicht bock so sinngemäß ach ja erzähl mal wo
bist du denn ist jetzt halt gerade relativ knapp weil eigentlich habe ich schon welchen zugesagt
zumindest das lief halt super mega schnell der hat mich gefragt dann habe ich mir den mal kurz
telefoniert da hat mir ein bisschen so was drumherum erzählt ja klingt gut weißt du was ich schicke
dir mal meine skillliste und lebenslauf und einfach nur für den fall der fälle wenn du das morgen
einem chef erzählst dass du jemanden kennst da hat er seinem chef meine skillliste und den
lebenslauf gegeben und ein tag später hat mich sein chef angerufen wo ich gerade im bauhaus
beim weihnachtsbaum kaufen war ja hier ist sowieso von sowieso und bewerbungen da meinten sie ja es
ist natürlich so es ist eine versicherung und da muss das alles super korrekt sein deswegen muss
ich mich noch mal online über ihr portal offiziell bewerben aber ich soll reinschreiben dass ich mit
ihm telefoniert habe und er hat auch schon bei der personalabteilung bescheid gesagt dass es
schneller geht also bin ich als ich heimgekommen bin vom bauhaus in das portal lebenslauf hochgelaufen
skillliste hochgeladen zeug ausgefüllt meinen bekannten dort eingetragen als empfehler das
ist immer wichtig weil mitarbeiter werden mitarbeiter mitarbeiter werben mitarbeiter
programme haben eigentlich fast alle du musst dann immer sagen wer dich geworben hat dann
kriegt ein bisschen kohle ist ja auch gut so und dann ging das eigentlich relativ schnell dann
habe ich mich dort beworben ich habe dazu gesagt dass mir wichtig ist dass ich 80 prozent teilzeit
arbeiten will ihr wisst ja braucht zeit für mein content zeug aus dem reicht mir die kohle
und dass ich teilzeit arbeiten will habe ich dazu geschrieben dann haben die das ein tag später
oder so bei ihnen besprochen und dann hat er mich abends angerufen hat gemeint ja habe ich ja ob
ich nicht ob ich nicht jetzt zeit habe die nächsten tage mal nach frankfurt wegen
vorstellungsgespräche und dann war ich ein paar tage später direkt in frankfurt glücklicherweise
alles noch bevor der andere vertrag in der post war weil ich wollte die auch nicht unnötig lange
hinhalten dort und dann war ich dort in frankfurt und ich fand das was die erzählt haben ziemlich
gut die fanden das was ich erzählt habe wahrscheinlich auch ziemlich gut und obwohl sie gemeint haben wir
sie brauchen eigentlich noch bedenkt also sie haben am anfang haben sie mir erzählt sie brauchen
noch ein bisschen bedenkt zeit haben wir uns trotzdem am ende des vorstellungsgesprächs darauf
geeinigt dass das eigentlich so gut passt also wohl von dem was ich den eindruck habe als auch
von dem was ich erzählt habe und wie der lebenslauf passen die skillliste passt dass
sie mir jetzt hier zusagen können dass sie mich einstellen weil ich habe dann auch gesagt gut
ich muss jetzt den anderen irgendwas erzählen kann ich kann ich jetzt nicht zwei wochen
hinhalten noch und dann irgendwie nächstes jahr sagen doch kein bock mehr ja und deswegen ging
das denn super schnell und gestern hatte ich den vertrag in der post das heißt vertrag wird gesigned
moment vertrag wird gesigned und dann werde ich nächste woche mittwoch wahrscheinlich dienstag
mittwoch nach frankfurt fahren kündigung abgeben in der personalabteilung also der
anderen firma ja das war mir echt peinlich ich habe der anderen firma schon was gesagt also
nachdem ich den vertrag die zusage dort hatte habe ich gesagt gut dann sage ich den in würzburg
jetzt ab das war mir wirklich peinlich weil sowohl die personalabteilung war das sehr nett als auch
die theoretisch zukünftigen kollegen ich konnte wirklich nichts negatives über die sagen also
an denen lag das wirklich nicht der grund warum ich mich fürs andere entschieden habe ist ganz
einfach erstens es ist in frankfurt was mir trotzdem irgendwie noch lieber ist als würzburg auch wenn
ich dort vielleicht ticken mehr hin muss aber immer noch deutlich weniger als jetzt und naja
was soll ich sagen ich mein geld ist zwar nicht alles aber letztendlich ist geld der hauptgrund
warum wir alle arbeiten gehen und die bezahlen in frankfurt einfach deutlich mehr was soll ich
machen da es ist mir von der location her lieber und es gibt deutlich mehr geld also naja gut
zumindest habe ich jetzt abgesagt und es war mir wirklich peinlich ich habe da angerufen bei der
personalabteilung ich war froh dass nicht die von der personalabteilung dran war mit der ich das
ursprünglich alles besprochen habe sondern der andere und ich habe ja gefragt ob es ausrichten
kann er macht sie meinem theoretisch dort zukünftigen chef habe ich so schon abgesagt über den chat den
kann ich ja vorher auch schon und ja war halt bisschen doof für die war für mich auch cringe
anzurufen zumindest abgesagt und jetzt ist das gelaufen nachdem ich jetzt auch den vertrag in
der post habe ist es auch gelaufen das heißt nächste wochen kündigung und ist das thema da
jetzt für mich für mich erledigt witzig von der bank zu einer versicherung und oder von der bank
zu einer bank kann man eigentlich fast schon sagen das bin mir nicht so ganz sicher wie das
ist aber von der bank zu einer versicherung ist wahrscheinlich treffender und
ja so genau was ich sagen wollte und es ist halt nur irgendwie 800 meter luftlinie unterschied
wo ich hin muss aber gut frankfurt bankenviertel habe ich jetzt auch nicht so viel geliegt leute
da ist alles im 800 meter umfeld egal ob deutsche bank und was sich alles ist dort in der gleichen
eckel nur die europäische zentralbank ist nicht mehr da die war früher auch da der europäische
zentralbank ist jetzt am ostbahnhof glaub irgendwo das ist dieses dieses gebäude was so was so
schepp aussieht vielleicht habt ihr das schon mal irgendwo in der den nachrichten gesehen
ja dieses das da das war so was so was so schepp und unförmig aus was von jeder was
sich von jeder seite kaputt aussieht das ist so schepp dass kein helikopter das glaube ich
nicht dass das der hauptgrund war eventuell war das ein mitgrund aber ich glaube das war
er war hauptsächlich das coole design es hat ein bisschen was von der ps4 ja das stimmt
es sieht wirklich ein bisschen aus wie eine ps4 aufrecht gestellte ps4 die sind halt nicht
mehr im bankenviertel jetzt so richtig in frankfurt alle anderen sind da aber noch
genau so jetzt lange noch darüber erzählt so sieht es aus bei mir aktuell ich mache
da auch noch ein video zu wenn ich den vertrag wenn ich die kündigung abgeschickt hat bzw.
abgegeben habe mache ich nächste woche noch mal ein video zu und erzähle euch das mal ein
bisschen im detail zumal hier auch jetzt nicht so viele leute da sind auf youtube youtube ja noch
viel mehr gucken so sehr zwichtig ehrlich gesagt es hängt es hängt das kammer so pauschal es
hängt davon ab was es für ein laden ist also wenn ich dich einstellen müsste werden mir
zertifikate komplett egal ja ich meine solange ich dich was fragen kann zu dem thema und du
antwortest aber sinnvolles drauf wenn ich damit keine probleme das mir egal im zertifikat hast
oder nicht höchstens als irgendwie netter netter hinweis im lebenslauf vielleicht wenn man sich
zwischen mehreren leuten entscheiden muss keine ahnung also ich persönlich würde das nicht so
viel wert drauf legen ich kann es ja aber pauschal so nicht sagen weil das jeder anders sieht
ich kann auch keine empfehlen ich habe wie gesagt ich arbeite nicht als software entwickler
hauptberuflich ich mache zwar hier viel software entwicklung im stream aber hauptberuflich bin ich
kein software entwickler ich habe mich jetzt entschieden ja vertrag ist auch schon in der post
gewesen dass jetzt durch es hat war der desktop so aufgeräumt ist sieht richtig kahl aus der
desktop denn den habe ich aufgeräumt weil mein startmenü geleckt hat das startmenü von winners
leckt ab und zu wenn der desktop zu voll ist warum man weiß es nicht das weiß nur microsoft
deswegen habe ich alles jetzt in diesen ordner geschrieben das ist alles vor dem desktop gewesen
ja ja ja jetzt bin ich senior ja senior
lohnt sich mittlerweile das update auf windows 11 das lohnt sich wenn du einen der neuen cpus
hast die unter windows 11 besser funktionieren wenn du zum beispiel 13.900k hast mit performance
course und efficiency course heißt der kram überhaupt so dann bleibt nur windows 11 wenn
es ordentlich benutzen willst weil nur der windows 11 multithread scheduler zeug das richtig kann
sind wir schon auf der neuen büchse was meint ihr leute sind wir auf dem neuen rechner oder
auf dem alten rechner ihr kennt mich alt richtig doch der alte ich habe heute angefangen alles
rüber zu schieben auf den neuen ich habe jetzt von be quiet das 12 volt kabel dran ich habe
noch eine zweite ssd eingebaut alles was sich so rumliegen hat habe ich noch eingebaut ich
habe noch eine zweite ssd noch zwei ich habe noch zwei weitere ssd eingebaut noch eine sata ssd
und noch eine m2 ssd jetzt kommt jetzt alles darüber und gut ist dann werde ich den einfach
eins zu eins austauschen und hinstellen danke für den einbruch ich weiß leider auch nicht ob eine
github einbindung ja github ist auf jeden fall sinnvoll also github habe ich auch reingeschrieben
bei mir ich habe ein github link reingepackt zwar zu dem einzigen projekt dass ich in letzter
zeit ernsthaft gepflegt habe alle anderen sind zwar da und haben auch komm jetzt aber da wo
ich mich wirklich drum gekümmert habe ist das hier guck mal mittlerweile 38 sterne auf github das
habe ich mit reingepackt weil ich habe als hobbies reingeschrieben heim automatisierung open source
entwicklung sonst habe ich das hier dazu dazu gepackt ja also github github links sind auf jeden
fall sinnvoll ich weiß nicht selbst wenn du dich selbst wenn du dich nicht als anwendung
entwickler bewirbst finde ich das nicht schlecht wenn du da irgendwas zum zeigen hast ja gut ja
kann man ja auch ich würde aber trotzdem was fragen ich würde ich aber ich würde dich
wahrscheinlich also wenn ich dich dann einschöpfen würde ich trotzdem so ein paar sachen fragen
weiß ja nicht ob du dein github account angegeben hast aber am ende und das ist halt auch wichtig
es hat halt keinen sinn wenn man sich einfach nur gut verkaufen kann dann im endeffekt nichts
kann es klappt natürlich auch das klappt vielleicht wenn ihr wenn ihr nicht so nicht
so findige chefs und personaler im vorstellungsgespräch habt klappt das vielleicht euch da durch
zu mogeln aber spätestens wenn ihr dann was machen sollt sieht man ja dass ihr keine ahnung
hattet wir hatten schon einige leute alles alles externe witzigerweise als externe eingekaufte
super teure experten hatten wir schon die haben nichts auf die reihe gekriegt wir hatten mal
ein der sollte irgendwas im zappings machen hat zwei wochen gebraucht sein notebook einzurichten
ohne scheiß hat zwei wochen sein notebook eingerichtet dann war er wieder weg
irgendein anderer der war auch geil der irgendein anderer der auf einmal nicht mehr aufgetaucht
ist wo alle schon gedacht haben der hätte irgendwie einen unfall gehabt oder so einfach
nicht mehr aufgetaucht und irgendwann meint er so ah ne das ist doch nicht der richtige
job für ihn und das war auch geil aber war er weg classic dankeschön für den zapp den
storage von dem storage experten habe ich ja schon erzählt der unser storage system
kaputt gemacht hat irgendwie am zweiten oder ersten aber als ich glaube am zweiten arbeitstag
war es und dann erst mal abgehauen ist und wieder gekommen ist später und dann quasi
seine sachen gepackt und abgehauen ist also wir hatten da schon echt ganz viel unfähige
leute das fällt halt auf irgendwann wenn du dich nur nur gut verkaufen kannst ja ja pauschel
pauschel habe ich tritt ja und wo wir gerade beim beim bewerbungsthema sind eine sache
muss ich noch erzählen und zwar kann sein dass ich den letzten schrieb schon mal erzählt
habe also da ist auch viel da ist auch viel beschiss im umlauf ja also kollege von mir
hat sich beworben auf eine stelle ich überlege gerade es war das ich weiß gar nicht wie
die stelle genau hieß geht man davon aus ist es auch so was wie senior admin oder sowas
oder senior linux engineer oder senior der fobs irgendwie sowas in der richtung zwar
es war was anderes ich komme nicht drauf aber es macht jetzt macht es keinen unterschied
zumindest die andere stelle ausgeschrieben hat er sich darauf beworben und die haben
reingeschrieben einer der wenigen die das reingeschrieben hat reingeschrieben haben
in die stellenanzeige die hatten reingeschrieben in die stellenanzeige eh preis also nicht
preis gehalts range 95.000 bis 105.000 oder sowas das haben die von sich aus von sich
aus haben wir reingeschrieben und das war für ihn der haupt ausschlaggebende punkt
dass er gesagt hat er bewirbt sich dort überhaupt wie gesagt wir gehen nicht alle just for fun
aber am endeffekt wollen wir alle geld verdienen klar gibt auch noch andere sachen die wichtig
sind aber geld ist sicherlich ein nicht zu unterschätzender faktor zumindest er hat
sich dort beworben auf diese stelle 95.000 105.000 und auch bei den ersten paar gesprächen
hat man ihm immer erzählt so ja alles klar das passt und er hat ihn halt erzählt wie
viel wie viel das jetzt jetzt gibt und darunter macht das auf gar keinen fall alle haben sie
immer gesagt ja passt alles wunderbar 95 bis 105.000 und dann hat er mit den vorstellungsgespräche
gemacht hat er mit ihnen sogar mal so nen so nen wir wie heißt das wo man so verschiedene
scenarien durchspielt da muss er mit ihnen verschiedene verschiedene fehlersituation
theoretisch durchspielen so nach dem motto ein wichtiger kunde hat angerufen dass sein
service xy nicht geht wie gehen sie jetzt vor und sowas in der richtung ticket workflow
entstörungsbla und sonst was zumindest das hat er mit ihnen durchgespielt am ende haben
die gesagt wunderbar wir würden sie wirklich gerne einstellen und angebot und konkret
kommt per mail so und auf einmal guckt er in seine mails rein und anstatt irgendwas
zwischen 95 105k steht da drin 75.000 obwohl die alle er wunderbar gepasst hat alles immer
angeblich gar keine frage war dass das so so so hinhaut und ansonsten super war gesagt
wie jetzt 75k ihr habt doch von anfang an gesagt mindestens 95 die stelle oder haben
die als ausrede angegeben ja das war ja eine senior stelle die wir ausgeschrieben haben
aber dass die die die die bidsche das management und das budget hat keine senior stelle mehr
zugelassen ist jetzt nur noch eine normale stelle und da denke ich mir gut da willst
er auch gar nicht arbeiten wenn die schon im vorfeld nicht wissen was die ausschreiben
keck bei haben wir dann gemacht wirklich weiß ich auch wenn das emote hat er dann gemacht
hier keck haben er keck bei noch ja so hat er dann gemacht einfach keck bei aber da muss
man sagen das ist schon hart an der grenze zu beschissen oder ich frage mich ich frage
mich ernsthaft was versprechen die sich davon meinen die jemand der dann quasi so viel energie
da schon reingesteckt hat der sagt dann ach da mache ich es auch für weniger oder also
was ist die was ist die idee dahinter mein das ist ja bestimmt nicht einfach zufällig
passiert das war bestimmt schon absicht was ist die idee dahinter das verstehe ich nicht
so genau weil letztendlich kannst du immer noch sagen die dann halt nicht die idee ist
schiben wird nicht auffallen ich weiß es nicht ich verstehe den sinn nicht nicht 20.000 20.000
weniger ich habe echt keine ahnung keiner vielleicht kriegen die sonst keine bewerber
und denken dann als haben wir den aber voll von uns überzeugender macht jetzt trotzdem ich glaube
die sind einfach lost keine ahnung das ist schon das ist schon wirklich ich bin mir gar nicht mal
sicher ob das überhaupt legal ist gut ich denke mal fehler dürfen passieren das nachzuweisen dass
das vorsätzlich passiert ist wahrscheinlich nicht können aber das ist schon das schon wirklich
harter beschiss gelesen so was haben wir hier ich will die neue ihk prüfung auch noch machen also
für fachinformatiker daten und prozessanalyse und digital die alten haben ich schon gemacht ist
da musste aber dich vorbereiten auf die neue abschlussprüfung also ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob ich heute aus dem ermel ohne jegliche vorbereitung noch eine ihk abschlussprüfung
gut schaffen würde weil die art wie die ihk fragt ist halt nichts was mit der realität zu tun hat
also muss auf jeden fall weihnachtsmusik oder spuk musik hier auch besser das muss man sich
auf jeden fall ordentlich ordentlich darauf vorbereiten dann schafft man das auch
du hast doch deine iot gerät in einem separaten wlan korrekt
mein homo system ist nicht dort drin mein homo system ist im internen netz
und also zwei sagen ich habe ein extra wlan für ich habe extra wlan für wlan geräte und ich also
für alle für alle normalen wlan geräte und dann habe ich ein extra wlan für alle also für alle
sagen wir wlan clients ein extra wlan und für alle iot geräte ein extra wlan und alles ist auch
jeweils ein unterschiedliches netz oben drüber und mein homo system ist auch in einem anderen netz
und dazwischen ist eine firewall die halt nur das durchlässt was gewollt ist also sprich aus dem
iot netz darf nichts außer mqtt darauf zugreifen und also die dürfen auch nicht ins internet die
dürfen ntp zum router und die dürfen mqtt zum homo system und aus dem normalen wlan netz dürfen
die auf das homo system web interface sonst auch nix für die extra für den sub hyper
subscriber ja wird man wird man wirklich zeit hier wo haben wir es denn ich habe
sie ich habe schon lange nicht mehr verwendet wo ist es denn was war das ja
für die subs leute
pro shot ist gerade free to keep wenn du nicht hast und neue einfach ein bisschen
vorzustellen will ich nicht pro short taugt das bei der team saut gerade von von mir was für
teams was meinst du ich habe doch hier kein teams laufen während ich streame doch klar
war das von mir verletzte hier kein irgendwie panik verursacher verleiten dass er denkt der
chef versucht kann anzurufen oder so das wollte ich jetzt nachgucken gerade ach so wie heißt
das ding pro schott ich gucke mal gerade auf einem iphone ob das was taugt pro shot excellent
ok das ist doch schon immer free oder oder es ist jetzt jetzt erst free na gut war weiter
klarate endchen sagt er hat zur mitte des jahres gewechselt auf eine 100 prozent homeoffice
stellen und fast das doppelte angehalten ist gut ja also das doppelte ist natürlich heftig das
doppelte habe ich jetzt nicht hey max hatte dich nach tipps zum programmieren gefragt hab jetzt mit
javascript angefangen macht echt spaß ist doch javascript ist zum einstieg wirklich nice vor
allem weil man nix braucht außer den editor und browser gerade wenn man einfach nur mal gucken
will so nach dem oder interessiert mich das überhaupt und man sieht halt auch gleich was
was mit leute gut soweit sind die nicht weggezogen aber schon ein stück so dass man nicht mehr
einfach mit dem auto hingekommen ist ja ja das ist total bescheuert ich bin total weiter dran
mit dem chat aber das total bescheuert also sie müssen sich wirklich nicht wundern wenn in die
leute wegrennen will ich nicht ich will noch den neuen vielleicht vielleicht vielleicht in einem
jahr oder so also hobbies hobbies im lebenslauf was habe ich reingeschrieben weiß gar nicht ob
ich es hobbies genannt habe ich glaube ich habe es noch ich glaube ich habe es nicht hobbies
genannt sondern weiteres oder irgendwie sowas ja da habe ich open source entwicklung hingeschrieben
was haben wir noch ich habe hingeschrieben dass ich selbstständiger nebenberuflich
selbstständiger webvideoproduzent bin das erste mal dass ich so was reingeschrieben
habe so ein paar sachen die hobbies habe ich glaube ich gar nicht reingeschrieben
ist ja was lustig da fällt mir auch was dazu ein es gab von es gab vor ein paar jahren mal
auch bei uns eine größere so eine größere versammlung ja und da konnte man im vorfeld
über irgendeine so umfrage seite fragen einreichen für diese veranstaltung und da waren also ein
paar richtig blöde fragen drinnen so nach dem motto warum sind keine bananen im obstkorb und
sowas richtig so richtig tolle fragen war da drinnen ja und und was haben wir gemacht was
haben wir gemacht wir haben uns mal schlau gemacht wie diese app votes zählt beziehungsweise ob die
anhand der absender ip zählt oder sonstigen schritte haben wir festgehalten nein nein nein
der macht das anhand von cookies fest also was haben wir gemacht einfach was gescriptet was
im hintergrund voted immer mit neuen browser sessions und am ende hatte diese blöde frage
warum gibt es keine bananen im obstkorb irgendwie 380 votes oder so und die nächste sinnvolle frage
hatte keine ahnung 105 oder hat er wirklich beantwortet hat er wirklich beantwortet ich
weiß ich ich weiß nicht mal was sie darauf gesagt haben ich glaube irgendwie so was drauf
gesagt sind ist er ist begeistert dass es so hohen anklang findet irgendwie der der obstkorb oder so
daco x tv dankeschön für den sub
delusional ist seit märz bei einer jetzigen firma kann er eine hand abzählen wie oft
die berühmten besser ohne scheiß ich bin auch der meinung unterm strich haben alle seiten was
davon klar es macht durchaus sinn bei manchen anlässen vor Ort zu sein auch mit mehreren
leuten keine frage aber unterm strich ist es aus meiner sicht für alle besser wenn man wenn alle
beteiligten das wollen wohlgemerkt wenn du jetzt jemand bist er sagt mir gehen die kinder die frau
die oma die mutter die und der opa wer auch immer ja mir gehen die leute daheim so auf den keks da
kann ich nicht arbeiten ich fahre lieber ins büro sollen sie machen das finde ich ja auch in
ordnung sollte man den leuten ja auch ermöglichen solange es eine firma ist ein unternehmen ist was
vor ort überhaupt noch räumlichkeiten hat aber alle anderen die das nicht wollen und wo man
gesehen hat bewiesenermaßen dass das gut funktioniert sollte man einfach machen lassen
schreiker 95 dankeschön für den sub excellent subscriptions umgedrehter bewerbungsprozess die
firmen kommen zu dir und du musst dich dann es war bei mir tatsächlich ein bisschen so ja also
bisher also auch dort wo es jetzt was geworden ist die haben mich gefragt halt über bekannte ja was
ich irgendwie auch ganz cool finde aber auf der anderen seite es hat sich halt keiner beworben
die haben halt händenring gesucht und die haben sich jetzt super gefreut dass irgendjemand noch
einer aufgegabelt hat und das dann auch so gut gepasst hat es waren keine viewer wobei
das waren auch viewer aber die kannte ich schon bevor sie viewer waren beste
so genau habe ich nie gesagt ich habe immer gesagt es ist jetzt sechs stellig und es ist
noch eine eins vorne so genau will ich es auch nicht sagen noch nicht noch nicht aber ja ungefähr
ungefähr ungefähr ungefähr das ist es was es jetzt aktuell gibt wohlgemerkt für fünf
tage gerechnet ja nicht dass einer denkt ich verstehe verdient sechs stellig mit vier tagen
auf fünf tage gerechnet hallo ich habe deinen stream mit der skill ist in opec sind wie baust du
das bei einer bewerbung ein alles in lebenslauf ich habe einfach ein zweites dokument ich habe
ein lebenslauf pdf und ein skill pdf dann habe ich noch eine zeugnis pdf ein zweites zeugnis pdf
abschluss pdf aber gut von den wichtigen sachen habe ich in lebenslauf pdf und in skills pdf
die prime subscriptions habe ich natürlich auch alle angegeben logisch ist es ja klar der jenige mit
mehr prime subscriptions ist kompetenter als der andere das ist logisch ist klar oder chat also
das sind das haben wir schon lange festgestellt dass iq und prime subscriptions ganz nah miteinander
zusammenhängen deswegen sind die leute ja auch so schlau weil hier so viele leute immer prime
subscriben bei IT Dienstleistern sind zertifikate immer wichtig weil man leute mit zerts teurer
verkaufen kann das kann gut sein da könntest du recht haben finde ich klingt logisch ja kann ich
mir vorstellen wobei die wahrscheinlich auch wert darauf legen dass die leute so was machen
ja wisst ihr was die beste frage war im vorstellungsgespräch glaube ich habe
schon erzählt aber ich fand es einfach lustig weil sie auch weil sie auch wieder gut in den
stream passt sie haben mich gefragt also jetzt bei der letzten stelle hat wurde ich gefragt
herr max was müssten wir denn machen was sie so richtig ärgert so sinngemäß haben sie sowas in
der richtung gefragt da habe ich gesagt ganz einfach wenn aus administrieren aber das hat
als antwort nicht gelten lassen er meint jetzt ja nicht technisch nicht technisch sondern halt
es ist so ich habe gesagt es ist aber so nirgendswo in meinem lebenslauf nirgendswo steht auch nur ansatz weiße windows drauf
von windows habe ich keine ahnung
github influencer naja mit mit einem projekt mit 38 sternen geht ab klasse danke für den
sub der letzte pilger ja gut bis kurz vor weihnachten angekommen finde ich top
für den primes ab
ihr hattet mal einen der meinte er kann frontend dann hat er seinen bildschirm geschrieben war zu
doof unser backend zu nutzen hat sachen auf dem desktop nehmen die seine papierkorb geschobbert
ja gut vielleicht war einfach auch nur nervös ja schwierig schwierig das jetzt so einzuschätzen
klar aber du hast einen ganz hohen anteil an unfähiger leute das habe ich auch schon
gemerkt gerade im consulting bereich wo ich mich immer frage consulting heißt doch eigentlich
nur wenn man zwar das wort so nimmt das ist jemand den ich hinzuziehe den ich quasi konsultiere wenn
ich selber nicht weiter weiß wenn ich wenn ich selber das nicht kann oder selbst keine ahnung
von habe oder nicht sie machen kann irgendjemand den ich dazu konsultiere weil er viel mehr plan
hat als ich ich habe wenige konsultants erlebt wo ich sagen würde ey krasser typ ja gibt gibt
durchaus ein paar wo ich sag oh die haben wir wirklich gerade von ihrem themengebiet richtig
ahnung aber ansonsten wenig wir hatten mal externe konsultants eingekauft für eine schulung das war
das war witzig ist jahre her da hatten wir ein produkt von einem us-unternehmen gekauft und wir
wollten natürlich wieder custom anpassungen dran haben und dann kamen unsere organisatoren auf die
idee lasst doch mal zwei leute aus den usa einfliegen die euch das alles mal ein bisschen zeigen und
erklären die sind dann eingeflogen aber was haben die gemacht anstatt großartig was zu
erklären waren in den ganzen tag oder den halben tag in irgendeiner wirtschaft in frankfurt und
haben bier und würstchen gesoffen also bier gesoffen würstchen und schnitzel gefuttert
den hat es richtig gefallen die haben den besuch in deutschland mega abgefeiert gebracht hat es aber
nicht allzu viel dafür haben sie richtig viel merchandise mitgebracht also ich habe heute noch
fünf usb sticks von diesem anbieter t-shirts notiz plöcke anhänger braucht zwar kein mensch
aber haben die haben quasi richtig im box von merchandise mitgebracht
lieg anbieter moment muss gucken ob sie noch gibt
wenn sie nicht mehr gibt dann zeige ich euch die gibt es anscheinend noch
moment
ane die sind konkurs ok dann kann ich euch zeigen welche anbieter das war ja die sind
konkurs da kann ich das kann ich jetzt zeigen alles klar die sind die hier waren das die sind pleite
ich weiß gar nicht was wir von denen hatten oder wir hatten glaube ich nichts direkt von denen wir
hatten aber irgendwas was die wo die schulungen gegeben haben irgendwie sowas ja und die haben
im prinzip eigentlich den halben tag würstchen schnitzel und bier zu sich genommen obwohl die
eigentlich know-how transferieren sollten die waren das er lang ich erinnere mich die hatten
sachen die waren in er lang programmiert ja also er lang ist quasi in programmierung sprache die
prinzip die sieht so aus dass es das ist quasi er lang hello world ja es ist es ist es ist nicht
nicht wunderbar mehr klammern excellent mehr klammern das ist toll mehr klammern gut lisp
ist die mutter der klammer klammer sprachen hast du weiter bildung gemacht damit du der
ob wir das nee ich habe technologien verwendet bevor es den namen des obs gab die aber in diese
richtung ging also wir haben beispielsweise angefangen bei uns mit das was jetzt unter
infrastructure as code läuft damals mit puppet war das zum größten teil noch heute heute ist es
mehr ansible versionsverwaltung in git also wir haben quasi auch continuous integration
continuous delivery gemacht bevor es richtig die coolen wörter dafür gab nee habe ich nicht ich
habe angefangen technologien in dieser richtung zu benutzen und irgendwann gab es dann einen
begriff dafür also ich habe da schon gemacht bevor es den namen dafür eigentlich gab
nasi schneiderman diagram ja korrekt also wenn ich jemand als software entwickler einstellen
würde das erste was ich testen würde ist natürlich ob der nasi schneiderman diagram kann chat wer von
euch kann kein nasi schneiderman diagram was ist das alter das heißt übrigens auch nicht
nasi sondern nasi ja das ich glaube schneider schade nicht so geschrieben ja doch schneider so so so was ist das das ist was was niemand verwendet und noch nicht mal der autor selbst ein paar jahre später für sinnvoll hielt das ist ein ablauf diagram wo man in der berufsschule mit gequält wird ist komplett useless braucht wirklich keine sau und es hat der erfinder der erfinder hat
schon gesagt dass es unsinnig ist nach ein paar jahren aber es hat sich aber es hat sich gehalten also ich habe auch nie im professionellen umfeld gesehen dass irgendjemand struktur kramme macht n punkt also mein ehemaliger spezialer zu mir mit dem ich auch ein video aufgenommen habe der meinte allerdings dass tatsächlich als sie programmieraufgaben nach indien outsourced haben dort gewisse sachen als struktur kramm vorgelegen haben um das dort zu übergeben mag ja alles sein
aber normalerweise also so habe ich so nicht gesehen wieso unsinnig ok also warum ist das meiner meiner warum ist das warum ist das unsinnig ich bleibe einfach mal dem beispiel weil es unglaublich groß und komplex wird bei nur sehr simplen sachen guck mal guck mal wie groß dieser und wie groß und kompliziert dieser block schon ist bei eigentlich nur zwei ifs das ist ja nix das sind if und niff das wird
unglaublich riesen groß und breit mit ein bisschen nesting du musst das komplett neu designen wenn du eine sache ändern willst und es ist auch nicht aussagekräftiger als einfach den den code exemplarisch hinschreiben also ich sehe da keinen sinn drin wirklich nett
wir müssen glaube ich mal anfangen mit dem eigentlichen strieb thema oder
muss du eigentlich eine ndna oder so unter keine ndna eine nda unter oder so unterschreiben wir nur künstlich habe schon eine nda unterschrieben für betriebsgeheimnisse
und sowas ich erzähle ja auch keine betriebsgeheimnisse erzähle euch abstrakt irgendwelche dinger die mal passiert sind unabhängig von der firma und jeglichen details und das konsultanz manchmal scheiße bauen ist jetzt ja nix was unter nda fällt sage ich nicht
neuers die scharp fern ist geboren ja weiß die scharp ist meine abstand meine lieblingsprogrammiersprache neben neben ihr wisst wahrscheinlich aber ich muss noch mal sagen neben ruby aber ruby verwendet heute keiner mehr weil ruby on rails outdated ist und was heißt outdated nicht mehr so hyped ist und deswegen verwendet keiner mehr ruby
welche aktivitäten findest du müssten sollten weiterhin im büro stattfinden tja also im marketingbereich kann ich es noch verstehen wenn die da super kreativ sein wollen zusammen was muss unbedingt noch im büro stattfinden es gibt ein paar sachen die sind aus technischer sicht sinnvoll
wenn die im büro stattfinden zum beispiel ganz praktische sache ja ganz praktische sache man macht netzwerk wartungsarbeiten netzwerk arbeiten die beispielsweise auch die vpn zum liemod arbeiten betreffen das willst du wahrscheinlich eher nicht von daheim machen und dich selbst aussperren nachts solche sachen kann durchaus kann durchaus ja was ich auch nicht schlecht finde beispielsweise wöchentliche teamrunde warum
nicht oder oder 14 tägliche teamrunde wenn man ein paar mal die leute sieht ist doch auch nicht verkehrt aber halt nicht dieses unsere office kultur ist so toll kommt mal alle wieder 100 prozent ins büro weil irgendwann muss man auch mal was ordentlich schaffen und das geht
bei mir zumindest daheim deutlich besser ich habe keine ahnung wusste gar nicht dass ein amazon store überhaupt gibt deutsche telekom sagt instagram verbraucht mehr terabyte pro tag als youtube
was soll denn terabyte pro tag überhaupt sein zu wachs oder ein terabyte pro tag ist eine einheit die so relativ wenig sinn gibt auf was bezieht die sich durchsatz an daten treffer traffic
kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen wahrscheinlich wird einfach instagram mehr benutzt weil so ein video braucht natürlich prinzipiell mehr bandbreite als bilder aber highres bilder und mehr benutzer ich kann mir das durchaus vorstellen
ja beides pro zeit ist immer durchsatz aber durch als kann doch beispielsweise ist es überhaupt nicht wenn ich zum beispiel sage wir haben einen datenzuwachs von drei terabyte am tag ist das dann auch für dich durchsatz und durchsatz von was aber ok das ist eine bandbreite quasi
netzwerk traffic ja ja aber in zuwachs würdest du auch so angehen wenn du sagst wir verbrauchen am tag fünf terabyte mehr fünf terabyte pro tag kommen zusätzlich dazu was das wären dann terabyte pro tag pro tag also jetzt gehts ab hier exellent
hrq chat du hast noch nicht mal prime subscrib du kannst dir gar keine so hrq sachen von ihr geben es ist quasi der kubik tag sozusagen taglitter das tagvolumen ist ein gehalt zu 100 prozent fix oder beeinhaltet ein gehalt noch einen variablen anteil
also jetzt egal es ist egal ob jetzt oder in zukunft ist er beinhaltet beides einen variablen anteil jetzt bei inhalt ein variablen anteil und mein neues beantrag er beinhaltet auch einen variablen anteil also es könnte auch ein bisschen mehr sein als das was man da jetzt was ich euch habe ja gar nichts gesagt
ich mache hier nichts auf chain law poste wäre komische dinge
wenn aus administrieren habe ich gesagt ja ich habe gesagt wenn aus administrieren
sie müssten sie müssten mich wenn aus administrieren lassen dass ich mich richtig aufregen würde
hast du mitbekommen dass die ukraine in aws importieren haben was der satz ergibt keinen sinn hast du mitbekommen dass sie die ukraine in aws importieren haben
ich verstehe nicht was du meinst aber selbst mit importiert haben verstehe ich es nicht hast du mitbekommen dass sie die ukraine in aws importiert haben was soll das bedeuten wie willst du ein land nach aws importieren
die haben ihre verwaltung nach aws verlegt ach so ja das ist wieder was ane und gut mit dem satz kann ich was anfangen das habe ich nicht verstanden so okay das ja warum nicht bietet sich ja an wenn du nicht willst dass dein rechenzentrum in luft gesprengt werden kann
welche musik läuft ihr feeling festiv feste feste feste was auch immer christmas holiday nintendo music
mani patate dankeschön für den sub prime subscription
und nie gemacht
ich glaube ich habe den chat bald bald bald habe ich den chat aufgeholt leute
struktur kramme
ja es gab den struktur eiser oder wie das ding hieß struktur eiser hieß das ding
das da
das da meint ihr gell den struktur eiser meint ihr das das kenne ich das das kennen
er das struktur eiser so ein schrottmann radiant razor nein radiant razor angeschönt für den sub
ja das stimmt ein select ist drei seiten lang quer nebeneinander gelegt in dem struktur kramm
was ist dein problem mit z plus plus schäler ist die frage ob wir heute noch mit dem eigentlichen
thema anfangen wollen oder nicht falsches emote wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht einplanen
weil wenn ich damit jetzt anfangen das weißt du genau dann fangen wir heute nicht mehr an was
sinnvolles zu machen ich habe letztes in den talk geguckt von es war eine z plus plus konferenz hat
irgendwann talk drüber gehalten dass er gerne wieder einen komplett weitere komplett neue
sonntags für funktions aufrufe in z plus plus einführen würde zusätzlich noch einmal du hast
vier verschiedene möglichkeiten wie du was aufrufen kannst da brauchen unbedingt noch eine
fünfte wichtig wichtig und richtig was ist web application elf in meiner taskleiste das
ist das womit ich bilder einblende guck das habe ich auf dem zweiten bildschirm hier da
kann ich ja drauf klicken und dann gibt es dann bilder oder sound den gibt es da nicht drin aber
wir haben wir haben auch wir haben noch wir haben noch verbotene emotes leute verbotene emotes haben wir drinnen
das salami emote ist noch drinnen oder oder oder die oma hier
und den hier hatten wir auch schon eine weile nicht mehr
ja das ist das ist web application elf
kennst du greylock vom namen habe ich glaube soweit ich mich erinnern kann ich verwendet bisher
sind das nicht zwei komplett unterschiedliche paar sachen ist ob servium nicht sowas wie
libre nms quasi sowas richtung nagios und und craylock ist irgendwas richtung log auswertung
war das nicht zwei komplett unterschiedliche paar schuhe ja dass die sind immer ganz vorne
ich frage mich ob die wieder wm statistiken rausbringen bei korn hab das während der während
dem wm finale irgendwie keiner geguckt hat und sowas die stelle deswegen fand ich tatsächlich
immer recht spannend mit eher schon ich glaube die haben keine andere probleme die haben die
haben eher das problem dass ihre rechnzeiten kaputt geschossen werden da ist alles nach
aws wahrscheinlich das kleinere problem das war nicht synchron zum gif stimmt das war
irgendwie verpackt warum war das nicht synchron zum gif was ist da los jetzt ist es synchron
zum gif ich habe den chat geschafft nice was machen meine updates updates fertig wir können
jetzt tatsächlich mal anfangen nach ich kann nicht tippen leute was ist hier los wir können
tatsächlich mal anfangen jetzt nach eineinhalb stunden lull ich sehe schon jetzt habe ich
wieder nicht genug energie und ausdauer dass wir was sinnvolles machen erst mal noch mal
hier update machen ja ja weg weg weg coolbox updaten erst mal alles updaten was haben wir
da im hintergrund was soll das sein ist das frankfurt ne das nicht frankfurt es ist es
könnte frankfurt sein ein bisschen dann bisschen zu viele hochhäuser was haben da jetzt aufgemacht
go land ich will nicht go land aufmachen alle ich will updaten check for updates go lull
für mal das nix in go und die palm ja miami triffts eher her frankfurter palm ja habt
die doch nicht gesehen zion ist da mein guckt eindeutig ok update update gut dann rebooten
wir und dann legen wir los also ich kann aber ein bisschen was erzählen was ich vorhabe
erstens bisschen mehr google was trinken kurz vorher ein bisschen google cloud wieder angucken
ein paar sachen auffrischen und ein bisschen was mit polumi basteln wo ich gerade in der
kombination noch nix gemacht habe der unterschied zwischen terraform und polumi ist dass man
in terraform eine eigene config sprache hat wo man ressourcen definiert und polumi macht
man das in schon existierende programmier sprachen von javascript bis go bis scharp
kannst du das alles machen und beides verwendet man dazu um cloud ressourcen zu professionieren
also man kann dann zum beispiel in seiner config sagen legen wir jetzt fünf vms an
machen wir fireball davor macht port 80 auf und keine ahnung starten webserver auf allen
fünf vms also man klickt nichts mehr selbst zusammen über die über das web interface
von irgendeinem cloud anbieter sondern macht das in der config datei lässt dann das config
management tool das für ein wow was passiert hier gerade monkeys was chat wer von euch
ist das schon wieder was macht ihr hier das sind neue icons ganz wichtig neue icons die
habe ich gebraucht so haben wir alles geupdatet zwar noch bis der package manager fertig ist
dann legen wir los aber hier alles dicht brauche man erinnert firefox neu starten wir starten
die ganze kurs also gcb gcp polumi getting started machen wir mal ein example von denen
getting started with google cloud also nur mal so als beispiel dass ihr mal gesät was
denn da am ende rauskommen soll was am ende rauskommen soll und zwar
so was kann man da zum beispiel machen so sieht es dann aus kann man beispielsweise einen
speicherplatz anlegen bei google bei der google google cloud location kona und dann kann man
dort was reinschreiben man kann darüber auch vms anlegen sowas das ist das was wir heute
probieren wir legen der vm an polumi ist ein config management tool ein infrastructure
as code tool damit kann man zum beispiel wenn man jetzt aws verwendet hetzener cloud verwendet
azure verwendet google cloud verwendet kann man anstatt im web interface oder mit der
kommando zeilen mit dem kommando zeilen tool darum zu vorwerken kann man komplette in dem
fall heißt decks man kann es quasi so environments auch nennen aufbauen anhand einer konfig datei
die man vorher angelegt hat also zum beispiel ich habe eine web anwendung denn immer das
mal als beispiel ich habe eine web anwendung ich möchte dass meine web anwendung auf fünf
verschiedenen vms parallel läuft mit einem load balancer davor und eine firewall am eingang
zum beispiel dann würde ich das in einer konfig datei definieren dass ich das so haben
will und dann wähle ich den klauenanbieter aus gut ne das stimmt nicht den klauenanbieter
muss ich vorher schon auswählen und dann sage ich einfach nur apply und dann legt es das
alles für mich an ich muss das nicht mehr selbst machen und ich kann dann auch sagen
destroy und dann ist alles wieder weg und das hat den weiteren vorteil ich kann nachgucken
wie es wie es konfiguriert ist also ich habe dann quasi meine konfig datei ist zeitgleich
quasi auch meine dokumentation dafür was ich da eigentlich mache das ist so der neueste
trend seit den letzten paar jahren dass man gerade im cloud umfällt eigentlich so gut
wie alles über solche provisioning tools macht solche konfig management tools oder
solche infrastructure as code tools oder wie auch immer nennst wie ihr wollt das verbreitetste
ist terraform polumi ist konkurrenzprodukt dazu was ich selbst noch nicht so viel verwendet
habe guckt zum beispiel gucken wir uns mal terraform exam also ich hab den noch gerade
neu gestartet ja gucken wir uns zum beispiel terraform example an nice geht er wieder sehr
schnell gerade das ist ein doofes tutorial ja so wird dann zum beispiel in terraform
das ganze angelegt werden gut dass jetzt aws terraform vielleicht simples google cloud
example credentials ja guck das ist der klau das ist beispielsweise aus der terraform konfig
der legt hier eine ressource an also eigentlich nur eine netzwerk ressource ohne da was dran
zu hängen und du kannst das normalerweise über das google oder über das aws oder über
das asher command line tool machen oder über das web interface oder du machst das halt
mit so einem provisioning tool oder dann zeigt gleich auch weiß was eigentlich passiert
wer was gemacht hat und du kannst einfach wieder löschen so haben wir jetzt updates gemacht
ich glaube wir sind fertig mit updates wie gut auf geht's let's go ich muss mich ja
noch bei google einloggen merke ich gerade das muss ich da muss ich euch mal kurz ausschalten
klein aber ja was was will eigentlich bei netzwerk manager hier das ist das bing image of the
day ihr müsst mich nicht fragen was es ist ich habe keine ahnung was man da sieht kauf
aus new york sagst du oder hast du gerade nachgeguckt also das heißt wir müssen jetzt
erste mal das zeug installieren jetzt mal ein weiterer vorteil von vms ich habe keine
ahnung was ich mir hier alles für den mist installieren muss aber ich habe da noch irgendwie
den alten snapshot ich glaube den lösche ich jetzt mal ich bin mir nicht sicher wofür
ich den angelegt habe ehrlich gesagt um 21 23 chat warum habe ich den angelegt 21 23
am zwölften am neunten zwölften lasst mal ins archiv gucken archiv wo bloß neunter zwölfter
bauen high end pc warum habe ich warum habe ich da ein snapshot angelegt ich war auf jeden
fall lange noch oder ist es der zwölfte neunte chat was meint ihr ist es vielleicht ist es
vielleicht auch der zwölfte neunte kann das auch sein dass es der zwölfte neunte ist
war da zwölfte neunte wird wahrscheinlich das war wegen dem windows iso tool das hatte
eine krabb dependency du hast recht der karlsruher dankeschön du hast recht ja genau ja gut da
behalten wir das mal bei aber reboot hat ja anscheinend funktioniert wie hieß denn dieses
dieses iso wo usb habe ich nicht installiert krabb ist auch noch mal drauf ok dann habe
ich den snapshot schon wieder restore und dann mal den snapshot jetzt aber den snapshot
weg delete jess oh nein vor allem wer please ok chat was machen wir jetzt bis vor allem
er das gelöscht hat warum dauert es vor allem wieder schon fünf stunden beim neuen pc geht's
schneller ich weiß nicht die vm liegt auf einer ssd ok die liegt dann auf einer noch
schnelleren ssd das könnte vielleicht was bringen ja wobei es geht ja nee wir gucken
jetzt kein youtube das dauert das dauert eine minute noch oder so dann ist das durch aber
ich muss auf jeden fall den snapshot vorher machen weil ich weiß nicht was ich da jetzt
alle installieren muss ich muss auf jeden fall polumi installieren google cloud installieren
oder wir machen den docker container und installieren uns den ganzen krempel da drin neues dotnet
muss ich installieren und und das google cloud tool muss installieren habe ich noch nichts
davon drauf warum nicht einfach altes system auf neuen rechner transferieren das mache
ich auch also windows installation nicht aber die ganzen vms und so die nehme ich alle mit
die ganze installation nicht ich will ja wenn aus elf auf neuen pc habe ich ja auch schon
ich habe auch die festplatte schon verschlüsselt festgestellt wer er kript hat ein problem mit
wenn aus elf 22 h 2 habe ich anscheinend um schifft weil ich schon die neueste version
installiert habe
sie denn sleeper oder oder mal um eine neun im aus zu verwenden bettgetheim vor allem wer
bettke ja die sind richtig gut geworden hat scheinbar das komplette system verschlüsselt
ja alles systempartition und alle platten die dran hängen und wisst ihr was das beste
ist an verschlüsselten platten nicht dass der cia oder der russische geheimdienst zu
eure sachen sich nicht angucken kann das ist vielleicht nebeneffekt wenn ihr da irgendwas
drauf habt was relevant wäre das beste ist dass ihr eure platten einfach wegschmeißen
könnt und ihr könnt euch sicher sein niemand kommt mehr an eure daten dran
das ist das beste stellt euch mal vor ihr habt eine ssd die nicht mehr richtig geht
oder eine festplatte die nicht mehr richtig geht ihr selbst habt keinen bock die irgendwie
reparieren zu lassen falls es überhaupt geht massig geld auszugeben ihr schmeißt die weg
aber vielleicht schafft ihr jemand noch was von auszulesen vielleicht sind das dann irgendwelche
passwörter von euch oder was auch immer und wenn die festplatte standardmäßig verschlüsselt
ist habt ihr damit überhaupt keine probleme weil dann kann er nichts mehr mit anfangen
selbst wenn er die noch auslesen kann dauert das lange zum verschlüsseln bei performance
verluste also performance verluste gibt es auf aktuellen plattformen nahezu keine mehr
weil alle aktuellen cpus is befehlsetze haben also du kannst is fair und entschlüsseln nahezu
ohne jeglichen irgendwie ohne messbaren verlust wie lange das initial dauert hängt davon
ab wie du das machst du kannst eine neue platte nehmen und einfach sagen verschlüsseln und
fertig das geht das geht das geht dann schnell das dauert zwei minuten hast du eine platte
wo noch daten vorher drauf waren oder hast du eine platte wo daten noch schon drauf sind
dann musst du die konvertieren lassen und am besten die anderen bereiche von der platte
überschreiben das heißt du musst einmal sagen wir du hast eine 12 terabyte platte das heißt
du musst einmal die platte neu beschreiben lassen verschlüsseln und dann neu beschreiben
verschlüsseln neu beschreiben das dauert bei der 12 terabyte platte so vier stunden
und bei der langsamen ssd auch bei langsameren ssd dauert auch lange bei der neuen ssd ging
das saumäßig schnell also bei mir die neue samsung ssd die 990 pro die hat das glaube
ich in acht minuten oder so gemacht die 2 terabyte oder so fertig verschlüsselt mein
desktop ist nur indirekt ordentlich alles unordentlich ist jetzt da drin ich habe das ordentlich
gemacht weil mein startmenü geleckt hat hey vor allem hat es geschafft also jetzt snapshot
machen snapshot weiterer vorteil wenn man vms verwendet vielleicht soll ich meine snapshots
mal sinnvoll nennen das könnten wir jetzt ja mal anfangen kommen hier snapshot manager
aha name dann weiß ich nämlich was ich gemacht habe wenn ich jetzt noch schreiben könnte
jetzt weiß ich nichts was ich da gemacht habe das habe ich mit veracrypt gemacht für windows
ja es gibt ja nichts anderes es sei denn ihr wollt bitlocker verwenden aber bitlocker
habe ich keinerlei vertrauen drin weil eines der ersten sachen damals die in der presse
war gewesen ist microsoft kann über den recovery key die sachen wieder herstellen wo ich mir
gedacht habe also ernsthaft verschlüsselung die man recovern kann ist keine richtige verschlüsselung
ich mag sein dass das mittlerweile alles viel toller ist tollere ist weiß nicht was laut
ihre hilfe sollen auf digitalen mähen versteckt information treffe sicher aufgespürt es geht
darum genügend bruchstücke einer gelöscht oder überschrieben oder zu finden ja gut es
bringt ja mit veracrypt kannst du da nichts kannst du da nicht wirklich was machen deswegen
musste die platte halt auch ordentlich verschlüsseln wenn da schon mal was drauf war was du halt
nicht wieder hergestellt haben möchtest und überschreiben wenn die platte neu ist und
nie was drauf war ist es ja kein problem das stimmt da hast du recht aber ich habe kein
bokunter zu fahren so also auf geht's erst mal neues dotnet installieren wobei nee muss
ich gar nicht wir haben doch jetzt dort net über package manager oder dort net stk 70.1
exzellent so gar nichts man polumi installieren polumi installieren wir über die wir machen
wir machen das tutorial wir machen mal das tutorial von denen also google glaubt bevor
du beginn install Heart
Da sind wir
Wenn ich das jetzt noch richtig erinnerung hat muss ich sagen pull umi
Login
Minus minus local wenn man den ihren webservice nicht verwenden will
Login in to progress es macht sehr gut dass so will ich das immer möchte noch niemand eingeloggt sein bei progress
Immer jemand any any logins
Kennst du dieses video hier
Eine chronologie des versagens das klingt ja schon wieder heftig ne kenne ich
Du bist schon drin
Ja, dann muss ich auch nicht mal einloggen so pull umi also machen wir das tutorial jetzt durch insta language install language
runtime haben wir gemacht
konfigure pull umi to access your google cloud account
Okay, ich muss google cloud tools noch installieren wie macht man das ich glaube die hatten auch ein download link in den tage z oder sowas
Achtung leute flashbang
Alter das haut ich haut ich weg okay download
Downloads
Keine ahnung mkd aber
Download mit karl cringe warum nicht einfach direkt mit weget easy
Und jetzt sollte man das installieren genau das war relativ easy
Achso xfz v
Und jetzt install welcome to google cloud cli do you want to help improve google cloud cli
null nein want to continue yes
in meine shell darfst du es reinschreiben
sehr schön
gut
repo
So jetzt sollten wir google cloud am start haben und pull umi am start haben wunderbar funktioniert
Also jetzt haben wir die tools am start das brauchen wir den ganzen kram nicht mehr bevor du beginn
Geh klaut aus application default login
Exzellent login da geht jetzt im browser auf und da muss ich euch leider ausblenden mal kurz
Weil ich nicht mein google google zeug liegen will
Oder oder versprecht ihr mir die augen zuzumachen chat macht ihr die augen zu dann ist auch ok
Die email adresse könnt ihr sehen das ist kein problem das ist ein fake fake account für
Hier zum was aber das password will ich trotzdem nicht liegen
Ich habe es gleich glaube ich muss auch gleich noch zwei fakta oder die fizierungen machen
Ich hoffe ich habe
Sehen sie auf ihrem feier nach was
Ich hab es gleich
Ich habe es gleich
clients
嘛
Boom
securely
exchanges
Two factor identifizierungen
Per capita
In deutschland wird mich da ja nichts wundern
Ich bin auf
funktioniert hat funktioniert alles klar okay mal wieder an wir sind authenticate
welcome sie arbeiten in first project alles klar gehen wir mal in wo ist vm übersicht
ne compute engine wo ist es denn da vm instanzen da sollte nix drin sein nein da ist nichts drin
sehr gut dann können wir uns das jetzt mal angucken also login haben wir gemacht wie
jetzt weiter polumi config set gcp das braucht man nicht mehr das weiß ich das braucht man
nicht mehr mittlerweile kann man das beim setup vom projekt selbst angeben mk dir quickstart
alles klar quickstart polumi new c sharp project für google cloud auf geht's project name
ja cute chat ja ja würde ich sagen heißt das description wunderbar stack name stack
ist das was bei polumi quasi ein environment gemeint ist also quasi eine gruppe aus firewalls
load balancern und speziellen ressourcen die man halt braucht um ihm eine sache bereitzustellen
man kann zum beispiel ein def stack und ein life stack oder so anlegen da kann man quasi
die gleiche umgebung hinstellen einmal zu entwicklungszwecken und einmal zu live zum
betreiben ist google cloud kostenlos es gibt eine trial da kannst du 300 euro ausgeben
einmalig ohne was bezahlen zu müssen und es gibt einen free tier wenn du unter diesem
free tier bleibst du ist auch kostenlos aber im free tier geht nicht alles ich glaube es
gibt beispielsweise keine vms im free tier wenn du wenn du den free tier willst mit vms
dann musst du in die oracle cloud problem ist nur die oracle cloud verwendet sonst keine
sau die einzigen leute die ich kenne die oracle cloud verwenden seriously verwendet jemand
oracle cloud für was anderes als für die kostenlose vm irgendjemand irgendwelche oracle
cloud hier google cloud projekt to deploy into ja moment warte mal wo haben wir es
denn hier ja wie heißt mein google cloud projekt wir hatten es ich hatte ich habe
es noch eben gesehen ja southern fields das kann ich aussprechen field alles klar
damit wir unsere idee auf weil der unterschied zwischen terraform und polumi ist das du
in terraform eine jammel datei anlegst wo du so deklarativ beschreibst was du machen
willst mit polumi hast du quasi komplette programmiersprache drumherum um deine cloud
ressourcen anzulegen kannst du quasi if einbauen select woanders was abrufen gucken von dieser
response was auch immer kannst du ganz als theoretisch kannst du viel coolere sachen mit
machen ist aber halt auch ein bisschen komplizierter. QChat Projekt. Trust.
Wir lassen jetzt mal wirklich nur dieses Test. Okay, als erste was wir jetzt machen ist mal das
Projekt hochstufen. Ach stimmt, das ist ja gar kein Jammel, du hast recht. Das ist ihre komische
ja, das ist natürlich, das ist ihr komischer Terraform-Inni-Dialekt. Ich weiß nicht,
wie ich auf Jammel komme. Klar, das ist ja ganz recht, das ist gar kein Jammel.
So,.NET 6 wollen wir haben und C-Sharp 11. Das neueste vom neuesten haben, Program.
So sieht also unser Testprojekt aus. Wir legen ein Bucket an. Also ein Bucket ist quasi so eine Art
Speicherplatz. Gibt es bei Amazon auch? Ich glaube Amazon hat mit S3 angefangen das Bucket zu
nennen und daraufhin nennen alle ihre Sachen, ihre Storage-Dinge, alle Bucket. Was? Return new Dictionary Bucket Name.
Ah ja, ich erinnere mich, das was man hier returnt, das ist das was man, wenn man das
Ganze mit JavaScript macht, ist das was man in diese Exports reinschreibt, wo ich dann drauf
zugreifen kann. Okay, wir lassen einfach mal jetzt das Testprojekt laufen. Da sieht man auch schon,
also was der hier jetzt macht, ist relativ simpel. Er legt einen Storage-Container an. Fertig. Das ist alles. Storage-Container, fertig, mehr gibt es nicht.
Aber ich zeige euch ja, da seht ihr auch gleich, was der Vorteil daran ist, das über so ein Tool zu
machen, also über das Web-Interface. Ach ja, das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Das ist überhaupt keine
Noob-Frage, das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Die Frage gibt es total oft und die stellen sich auch viele
Leute. Also, dazu kann ich was sagen. Also wie gesagt, das ist überhaupt keine Noob-Frage,
das ist wirklich eine gute Frage. Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen sowas hier, wie Terraform und
Pulumi und sowas wie Ansible, wie sie direkt einbringen in die Cloud-Dienstleister. Also,
du kannst ja in Ansible auch recht easy mittlerweile irgendwelche Cloud-Provider einbinden. Es gibt
für Azure ein Provider, es gibt für Hetzener Cloud sogar ein Provider, was Ansible angeht. Der Unterschied
ist einfach der Schwerpunkt der jeweiligen Tools. Die haben Überschneidung. Also, du kannst mit
Ansible, sagen wir jetzt, nehmen wir mal Hetzener Cloud. Ich überlege gerade, ob ich kostenlose Werbung
machen soll. Also nehmen wir mal zum Beispiel Hetzener Cloud und ich verwende gerne Hetzener Cloud,
muss ich sagen. Ja, das ist für mich persönlich so privat auch zu verwenden, super, weil es viel
simpler ist als jetzt Google oder AWS oder Azure. Einfach, es ist nicht, es kann bei weitem nicht so
viel, aber einfach zum VMs anlegen in Load Balancer davor ist Hetzener Cloud, super. Ja,
der Code geht leider nicht mehr, mein Hetzener Promo Code. Also, der Unterschied ist einfach,
wie der Schwerpunkt liegt. Du kannst zwar in Ansible auch jetzt eine Cloud-Resource anlegen
oder sowas und du kannst auch in Pulumi oder Terraform dein Server ein bisschen konfigurieren,
aber die Stärke von Ansible ist, die VM oder sagen wir mal das System, es muss ja keine VM sein,
ja, sagen wir mal das System, zu konfigurieren und die Stärke von Terraform und Pulumi ist,
die Systeme anzulegen in der Abhängigkeit und in der Anzahl und Menge, die man braucht. Also,
zum Beispiel würdest du, ja gut, vom Ansatz her klar, aber die zwei Tools, es ist egal,
ob es deklarativ ist oder nicht, die Tools sind für unterschiedliche Schwerpunkte ausgelegt.
Also, mit Ansible konfigurierst du deine Systeme und mit Terraform und Pulumi professionierst du
deine Systeme, wie man das so schön nennt. Also, mal angenommen, du möchtest jetzt eine
Web-Anwendung betreiben und für diese Web-Anwendung brauchst du ein MongoDB-Cluster,
haben wir mal ganz super NoSQL, High IQ Shit, brauchst MongoDB-Cluster oder du brauchst Cassandra,
du brauchst eine Datenbank, scheiß egal, du brauchst eine Datenbank, du brauchst eine Postgres,
kannst du sagen, brauchst eine Datenbank, du brauchst drei Application-Server für deine
Web-Anwendung, dass da ordentlich User drauf kommen, du brauchst eine Domain, du brauchst
ein Load Balancer, du brauchst eine Firewall und du brauchst DNS-Einträge. So, das würdest
du in Terraform machen. Du würdest dann in Terraform die Konfig anlegen, dass du drei
Application-Server bekommst, ein Load Balancer bekommst, DNS-Einträge bekommst und dann drückst
du in Terraform oder in Pulumi auf Start oder Up und dann legt er dir das alles für dich an.
In der richtigen Reihenfolge besorgt er dir Zertifikate, richtet DNS-Namen,
das kannst du in Ansible irgendwie nachbauen, aber nicht so schön, wie das mit Terraform
möglich ist. So, und wenn die Systeme dann stehen und die Systeme komplexere Konfigurationen brauchen,
dann nimmst du Ansible, um die Systeme zu konfigurieren. Also du lässt dir beispielsweise
in Terraform deine komplette Umgebung für deine Web-Anwendung anlegen, zwei Datenbank-Kisten,
drei Application-Server, eine Monitoring-Kiste, eine Logging-Kiste, eine Firewall, ein Load
Balancer, Zertifikate, DNS-Einträge, das lässt er dir alles anlegen von Terraform oder Pulumi und
wenn du dann Konfigurationen brauchst, die komplexer sind für die Datenbank-Kisten, für deine
Web-Anwendungskisten, das machst du mit Terraform. Das machst du mit Ansible, das machst du nicht
mehr mit Terraform. Also was du nämlich machen kannst, zum Beispiel in Terraform oder Pulumi ist,
du kannst minimale Konfiguration an den Kisten vornehmen, du kannst zum Beispiel einen Start-up
Script machen oder Cloud-Init ein bisschen anpassen. Das war es dann aber zum größten Teil.
Eigentlich musst du dann Inline-Bash-Skripte machen. Also wenn es mehr ist als Cloud-Init anpassen,
musst du Inline-Bash-Skripte machen in der Terraform, dass du den Server danach konfigurieren
kannst, wenn er erstellt wurde. Das heißt, du konfigurierst deine Systeme mit Ansible und du
legst deine Systeme an mit Terraform. Die haben gewisse Überschneidungen, ja du kannst Systeme
bis zu einem gewissen Grad in Terraform konfigurieren und du kannst auch bis zum gewissen Grad Systeme in
Ansible anlegen, aber die Stärken ist eindeutig Ansible-Konfiguration und Terraform-Provisioning
und Anlegen. Was Cloud-Init macht, Cloud-Init ist so ein Standard-Yaml-File, was initial ausgeführt
wird, wo du SSH-Config einstellen kannst, IP-Adressen, DHCP und so Sachen. Wo du ein paar
Sachen an deinem Server konfigurieren kannst. Aber was in Cloud-Init halt nicht drin ist,
ist das nicht drinne. Hast du es verstanden? Syllabs? Also das ist tatsächlich so der Schwerpunkt ist
das Entscheidende. Theoretisch kannst du alles mit beidem machen, aber es ist halt unglaublich
auffällig, das ordentlich zu machen und geht auch gar nicht so richtig. Also du willst eigentlich
in Ansible keine Cloud-Umgebung irgendwie provisionieren lassen. Du kannst auch mit Cloud,
ja klar, du kannst sogar Cloud-Init ausführen und in Cloud-Init kannst du ein Inline-Script
ausführen, was dann Ansible ausführt. Das geht alles. Es ist auch sinnvoll, das so zu machen.
Ja, exellent. So und jetzt zeige ich euch schon mal einen Vorteil dieser ganzen Geschichte. Also
die Standard-Config ist simpel. Der legt einfach einen Speicherkontainer an in der Cloud, wo man
dann was drin speichern könnte. So könnt ihr euch das vorstellen. Ein Eimer heißt Bucket,
heißt Eimer oder? Der legt quasi einen Storage-Eimer in der Cloud an, ohne dass er was reinschreibt.
Einfach nur ein Eimer und den nennt er My Bucket. Jetzt könnt ihr mal einen weiteren Vorteil von
solchen Provisioning-Tools sehen. Wenn ich jetzt sage, Pulumi ab und ich hoffe ich habe
dir nichts vergessen. Ja, Pulumi hat eingebaute Secret-Management, was ich auch mega nice finde.
Das heißt, alle Secrets kann ich ins Repo mit einchecken, wenn ich das will. Die sind verschlüsselt
und ich muss ein Passwort eingeben, dass ich die entschlüsseln kann zur Runtime. Das Passwort muss
ich mal überlegen, wo ich das speichere oder aktuell habe ich es im Brain gespeichert. So,
jetzt guckt Pulumi erstmal nach. Was soll ich denn überhaupt machen? Okay, der muss einmal das
Projekt erstellen. Das dauert initial jetzt ein bisschen und muss die ganzen Libraries installieren,
weil wir lassen das jetzt ja das erste Mal laufen. So, und jetzt sagt er, okay, ich habe
deine Config mir angeguckt. Was du machen möchtest ist folgendes. Du möchtest hier
ein Bucket anlegen. Mehr nicht. Und jetzt kannst du sagen, ja, ups, ja, stopp. Wenn man nicht die
Error-Keys hittet, ja. What the fuck? Ich drücke Pfeil nach oben und es geht nicht? Was? Unexpected Sequence? Was? Ist das ein T-Mux-Problem?
Ist das ein T-Mux-Problem? Lass uns mal checken. Nö, jetzt geht's. Okay, was auch immer. So, jetzt sagt
er mir hier folgendes würde ich machen. Ein Bucket anlegen. Jetzt sage ich, jawoll,
legt mein Speicherkontainer an. Jetzt macht er das. Sofern ich das aktiviert habe in der Cloud. Kann
sein, dass ich das vorher noch mache. Passt. Bucket ist da. Bucket wurde angelegt. Guck hier. Bucket
Name. Blablabla. Hier. Da kannst du so mit drauf zugreifen. Und jetzt ist das Gute. Jetzt ist das
Gute, wenn ich einfach alles, was ich angelegt habe, wieder löschen will, sage ich Pulumi Destroy
und dann entfernt er rückstandslos wieder alle Ressourcen, die er vorher angelegt hat. Ja,
es ist im Prinzip das gleiche wie Terraform. Also von der Idee her ist das gleiche. Der größte
Unterschied ist eigentlich, es gibt sogar irgendeinen Adapter, dass du Terraform-Module für Pulumi
verwenden kannst. Wo landet das Date hier irgendwo drin? Dachte ich eigentlich. Gut,
ich habe es jetzt Destroyed. Vielleicht sollte ich es mal wieder anlegen. Können wir gleich gucken?
Ich glaube, ich bilde mir ein, das Date landet im kleinen Verzeichnis. Das ist nur die Anwendung an
sich. Müsste dann hier irgendwo sein. Also Date könnte man theoretisch auch einchecken, wenn man
das will. Genau, jetzt hat er rückstandslos wieder alles gelöscht. Das heißt, ihr erkennt jetzt
schon im Ansatz, warum diese Tools so beliebt sind. Wenn ich jetzt hier drinnen 20 VMs anlege,
Load Balancer, DNS-Namen und sonst wie für eine Webseite, für eine Web-Anwendung und ich will
die irgendwann mal wieder löschen. Dann muss ich nicht drei Stunden in der Cloud-Interface rumklicken,
bis die wieder weg ist, sondern sag einfach Destroy und erlöscht die Sachen wieder.
Also, wir gucken jetzt mal, wie man VMs anlegen kann. Das ist nämlich das, was ich mir mal
anschauen will. Wie legt man mit Pulumi beispielsweise in … wie legt man mit Pulumi VMs an in der Google
Cloud? Also sowas hier. Ja. Compute Engine VM Instance. Wie legt man hier VMs an? Also,
da müssen wir mal hier suchen. JCP Compute Instance heißt dieser Krempel da. JCP Compute Instance.
Wer von euch hockt auf der Arbeit und schaut den Streamern? Ich weiß, dass es einige machen. Wie
viel kostet die Google Cloud? Es gibt irgendwo einen … Also, du hast das Dios Report. Es gibt
auch irgendwo einen Kostenrechner, glaube ich. Ich kenne jetzt nur den Azure-Kostenrechner.
Calculator. Genau, den gibt es hier auch. Ja, da kannst du den Krempel … So, was was ich
sagte, du willst fünf VMs haben. E2 sind die billigen. Ich habe übrigens keine Ahnung von der
Bezeichnung, warum die Dinger so sind. Ich weiß es nur. E2 sind die günstigen VMs. Medium wollen wir
haben. Shared Core, die sind noch ein bisschen billiger. Shared Core Medium. Oder komm, nehmen
wir mal Shared Core Small. Keine Ahnung, 10G. GPUs brauchen wir nicht. Wir wollen nach Europe,
West, Frankfurt … Koste dich fünf Kisten, kosten dich ungefähr 78, 78 Dollar im Monat.
Da sieht man, das ist fucking teuer für VMs, für so kleine VMs. Das ist abfuck teuer. Also,
reines VM-Hosting würde ich da drin beim besten Willen nicht machen. Total, guck mal, 85, 85 Dollar
für fünf Popel VMs. Das ist abfuck teuer. Bei Hetzner kostet euch der ganze Krempel. Gucken
wir mal. Hä, was war das gerade? Bei Hetzner kostet euch der Kram. Nehmen wir mal das kleine,
dann habt ihr sogar noch mehr Disk Space. Guck mal, da kosten euch fünf Stück 20 Euro im Monat.
25 Euro, ja. Hey, das hat andere … Ich sage gar nichts dazu. Das hat andere Vorteile. Gerade,
wenn du die restlichen Google-Services noch verwenden willst, reines VM-Hosting würde ich
da wirklich nicht drin machen. Unabhängig von SLAs, Hetzner wird sicherlich auch SLAs haben,
und du hast bestimmt, wenn du das für einen Enterprise-Fall benutzt, Möglichkeiten,
was zu machen, garantiert. Sonst würden die sich ja prinzipiell für jede professionelle Nutzung
ausschließen. So blöd sind die bei Hetzner auch nicht. Wenn du aber noch andere Services verwendest
in Kombination, du kannst natürlich in der Google-Cloud viel, viel mehr machen als in der
Hetzner-Cloud. Dafür, wenn es um reine Sachen wie VM-Hosting geht. Oder selbst wenn du einen
Managed Kubernetes-Cluster brauchst, da kannst du in Digital Ocean gehen. Digital Ocean und Managed
Kubernetes-Cluster, dafür nicht den ganzen anderen Krempel, was AWS, Escher und Google anbieten.
Also man muss halt gucken, was man braucht. Wenn du allerdings die ganzen anderen Sachen benutzen
möchtest, möchtest du Functions verwenden. Willst du vielleicht Google Maps … Ich meine … Guck mal.
Hier, ohne Scheiß. Google ist übrigens auch der Cloud-Anbieter, wo ich so gut wie nix finde.
Bei Escher blicke ich im Web-Interface ziemlich gut durch mittlerweile. Bei AWS, die Bezeichnung ist
VR, aber irgendwie sieht AWS oldschool aus, aber man findet noch halbwegs was. Aber Google, ohne
Scheiß, ich finde hier nichts. Nichts. Ich brauche immer zwei Stunden, bis ich was gefunden habe.
Also hier kannst du halt alles machen, was es so gibt. Dafür ist halt so eine einfache
VM ein bisschen teurer. Aber gut, ich habe noch 286 Euro, die ich ausgeben kann.
Okay, also wir gucken uns jetzt mal an, wie man hier eine … vor allem anlegt, bei Google,
mit Pulumi. Also, GCP compute instance. GCP gleich Pulumi. GCP? Hä? Kann ich einfach sagen GCP?
Doch da. Hä? Compute. GCP ist Google Cloud Platform. Genau. Ja. Ach, jetzt weiß ich,
warum die das so gemacht haben, dass man das abkürzen kann. Nee, das machen wir nicht. Wir
sagen einfach using Pulumi GCP und dann schreiben wir im Endeffekt nur noch hin Compute … äh,
warum geht das jetzt nicht? Ach, weil das ein Namespace ist. Ist das ein Namespace? Ach,
das ist ein Namespace. Nee, dann machen wir halt nur instance. So, auch okay. Nur instance. So,
instance. Also, was brauchen wir da? Jetzt machen wir VM gleich new instance. Was muss man da angeben?
Name. Okay, und jetzt … wir versuchen gleich mal die Vorteile von Pulumi versus Terraform
beispielsweise mal auszunutzen. Ich meine, ich weiß, man kann in Terraform auch Schleifen machen,
aber nicht so schön wie so hier. Also, sagen wir mal so, wir machen jetzt eine Schleife,
sind wir mal ganz … Schleife 1 bis 5 oder 1 bis 4 und legen da drinnen jetzt mal VMs an. Also,
wir wollen 4 VMs haben. Der Name ist App oder … Web App, Web App, Bindestrich, 0 bis Bindestrich
oder fangen wir … Chat, fangen unsere Server-Namen bei 0 an oder bei 1? Bei 1,
ha? Server-Namen bei 1 ist okay. Bei 0? Okay, weil ihr seid 0. Bei 69. Web App. Also,
die Dinger heißen Web App, Bindestrich, 0, Bindestrich, 1, Bindestrich, 2. Und wie geht
das jetzt weiter? New. Ne, Compute Instance. Also, New. Machine Type. Okay, also, New.
Machine Type. E2 Medium oder E2 Small. Zone. US Central R. Ne, wir wollen Europe West. Oh ne,
das weiß ich doch aus dem Kopf nicht, wie dieser Kram heißt. Also, guck mal, GCP, Zones,
was gibt es denn da alles? Hier. Europe. Europe. Hier. Europe West Frankfurt. Wo ist
Frankfurt? Da, Frankfurt. Europe West 3A. Genau da. Da will ich meine VM haben. So,
wie geht es weiter? Tags brauche ich nicht. Tags interessiert mich nicht. Boot Disk. Da
muss ich jetzt auswählen, was ich für ein Betriebssystem drauf haben will. Also, in dem
Fall Debian 11. Debian 11 ist gut. Debian 11 nehmen wir mal. Boot Disk. Ach so, Alter bin
ich blöd. Lul. Warte mal. Ist weg. Hier muss das rein. Boot Disk. So. Instance Boot Disk
ARKS. Was hat er denn jetzt für Schmerzen? By the way, was ist hier eigentlich? Warum
ist das so doof formatiert? Ja, so viel, viel besser. Zwei Spaces. Ich bin gerade nicht
so richtig in der Lage, gescheit zu copypasten, oder? New. Instance Boot. Jetzt passts wieder.
Die Musik ist mir gerade ein bisschen zu sehr zum Einschlafen. Ah ja, besser. So, also wir
legen eine VM an. So, jetzt erkennt man wenigstens auch was. Also wir legen eine VM an, die
diese E2 Small Typ, also quasi eine Shared CPU und zwei Gigabyte RAM oder sowas, hier
in Frankfurt. Als Betriebssystem wollen wir Debian haben. Jetzt brauchen wir sonst noch
Scratch Disks. Brauchen wir nicht. Network Interfaces. Network Interfaces brauchen wir
auf jeden Fall. Sonst wird das nix. Copypaste das jetzt einfach mal. Das geht schon mal
nett, weil, was auch immer. Schön, wenn die Beispiele nicht funktionieren. Das ist aber
eine komische Syntax, oder? Kann man das nicht einfach weglassen? Oder mag er das nicht?
Okay, also wir haben jetzt eine Kiste mit Debian drauf. Probieren wir mal aus. Wir probieren
es einfach mal aus. Also, was er jetzt machen sollte ist, er sollte vier VMs anlegen. Er
sollte vier VMs anlegen und zwar Web App 0 bis Web App 3, jeweils eine kleine VM mit
Debian drauf und dem Default Network, die nicht extern erreichbar sind. Extern erreichbar
müssten die mit irgendeiner Firewall davor sein. Schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Pulumi ab. Unrun Dead, genau deswegen gefällt mir das auch unglaublich gut. Man kann eine
ordentliche Programmiersprache verwenden. So, mal gucken, ob jetzt alles funktioniert,
ob ich irgendwie Mist gemacht habe. Pulumi ist quasi sowas wie Terraform, ein Cloud Provisioning
oder Infrastructure as Code Tool, wie man das so schön nennt. Do you want to perform
this upgrade? Also, was er jetzt machen würde ist, er legt, guck mal, er hat das erkannt,
er hat das erkannt, dass das das ist, was ich machen will. Er hat gesagt, deine Config
ergibt vier neue VMs mit diesen Namen. Das ist ja das, was ich hier im Prinzip auch eingestellt
habe. Ja, ich habe eine Schleife gemacht. Ich habe eine Schleife gemacht mit jeweils
paar VMs drinne. Ja, ok, perform this upgrade, update, yes. Das dauert jetzt ein bisschen
und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob alles funktioniert, ob ich nicht noch irgendwie was anschalten
muss im Vorfeld. Sehen wir gleich. Wir können schon mal reingucken, VM Instances, ob sich
da was tut. Da sind sie doch schon. Bam. Guck hier, da sind wir. Interne IPs haben sie.
Europe West Name Web App Null. Exakt so wie es sein soll. Hat vier neue VMs angelegt.
Ganz fertig ist er noch nicht. Vier VMs. Easy. Guck, jetzt hat er vier VMs. Und das
ist so deutlich schneller und deutlich reproduzierbarer, als das über das Web Interface zu machen.
Jetzt kann man sich übrigens auch auf diese VM schon connecten. Kann ich zum Beispiel
hier mal auf SSH klingen. Das dauert jetzt kurz. Das war am Anfang in meinem Google
ganz so schnell. Dann kann ich mich direkt im Browser per SSH auf diese Linux VM verbinden.
Wenn ich das nicht machen will über den Browser, kann ich das auch über das Google CLI Tool
machen oder ich kann es theoretisch auch, wenn ich SSH extern freischalte, kann ich mich
da auch so per SSH drauf verbinden. Also 0HD 4K. Da bin ich. Da bin ich in meiner Linuskiste
drin. Jetzt haben wir vier Linuskisten angelegt. Und jetzt ein weiterer Vorteil, das da zu
machen, wenn ich sage, ok, eigentlich brauche ich den Kram doch nicht mehr, sage ich Destroy
und alle diese VMs sind wieder weg. Wenn wir jetzt gleich, Moment. Was ist das da ganz
oben links, wo die Fenster umgeschaltet sind? Warum ist das so klein? Das hier. Weil das
sieht standardmäßig so aus. Achso, das ist nicht Windows. Das ist eine Linux VM mit I3.
Die Standard I3 Bar sieht schon relativ ähnlich hier zu aus. Ich habe jetzt noch Eigens dazu
gemacht. Ich habe noch Eigens dazu gemacht und hier hinten die Statusleisten ein bisschen
anders gemacht. Aber ansonsten ist da eigentlich nicht so viel Customized. Wenn wir das gleiche
noch mal ausführen, dann fällt es ja wegen den Namen. Da bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt gar
nicht so sicher. Achso, in dem Fall fällt es, weil er den State erkennt. Wenn wir das
noch mal ausführen, dann fällt es nicht. Weißt du was passiert, wenn wir das noch mal ausführen?
Zeige ich dir. Das passiert nämlich gar nichts. Das kann ich dir zeigen, wir müssen aber kurz
warten bis es gelöscht ist. Löschend dauert witzigerweise, ich weiß nicht warum, löschend
dauert immer viel länger als anlegen. Ich verstehe den Sinn davon nicht so ganz, aber
es ist so. Also löschend dauert teilweise Minuten und anlegen dauert 5 Sekunden. Warum?
Man weiß es nicht. Wahrscheinlich müssen sie im Hintergrund mehr machen. Guck mal wie
lange wir brauchen was zu löschen. By the way, ihr könnt Pulumi auch mit Hetzner Cloud
und anderen Anbietern verwenden. Also das ist nichts, was festgelegt ist auf Google.
Nächste Ressourcen bringen kein Geld. Ja das verstehe ich, da muss man natürlich schon
ein bisschen klauselig sein. Also du kannst das so ziemlich jeder Plattform finden. Es
gibt Provider für Google, für AWS, für Azure, für Hetzner, für Digital Ocean, für Linode,
für OVH, wahrscheinlich auch alles mögliche. Unrun Dead, das ist eine gute Frage, das zeige
ich euch jetzt mal. Das ist nämlich eines der Kernansätze von so Sachen wie Terraform
und Pulumi. Also seine Frage ist folgendes. Wie würde man denn vorgehen, wenn man schon
viel angelegt hat, aber irgendwie noch viel weitere bräuchte? Also das ist eigentlich
eines der zentralen Fragen solcher Provisioning Tools. Also wir legen das ganze jetzt nochmal
an. Ich habe es jetzt zwar erst gelöscht, aber wir legen es jetzt einfach nochmal an.
So wir legen jetzt nochmal 5 VMs an. Oh die alten sind noch gar nicht richtig weg. Ich
hoffe das gibt es kein Problem. Ey doch, sind weg. Also jawoll, wir legen die neuen VMs
an. Jetzt zeige ich euch, wie das funktioniert. Und ich könnte Pulumi auch in einem simplen
Python Script verwenden. Ja, du kannst Go, Python, TypeScript, Python, Go, C Sharp Java
oder in ein eigener Jaml Dialekt. Allerdings, also in vielen Fällen sparst du da nicht so
wirklich was versus Terraform, weil du musst ja immer noch lernen, wie die Dinge heißen
und was du da ans Parameter reinstecken musst. Das ist jetzt auch nicht so unterschiedlich.
Ich persönlich finde es halt cooler, die Möglichkeiten zu haben, eine ordentliche Programmiersprache
drum herum zu haben. Ich meine, wer schon mal Schleifen in Terraform gemacht hat, kennt
das. Oder auch Schleifen in Ansible. Das geht alles. Aber merkt, irgendwie so richtig gedacht
ist es nicht. So, VMs sind angelegt. Und jetzt kümmern wir uns um die Frage von Unrun Dead.
Also die erste Frage ist, oder Chat, ich frage euch mal, was meint ihr denn, was passiert,
wenn ich das gleiche nochmal ausführe? Also ich habe jetzt gesagt, Pulumi, starte mal meine
Umgebung. Pulumi hat gesagt, oh ja, dafür muss ich diese Dinge anlegen. Was passiert,
wenn ich es jetzt nochmal ausführe? Nochmal Pulumi ab. Ergibt aus, dass er die bereits
erstellt hat. No changes detected. Genau, so ähnlich. Pulumi hat sich ja gemerkt, was
es gemacht hat. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt sage, Pulumi ab, sagt er, aha, das gibt's
ja alles schon, ich muss ja gar nichts machen. Ja, guck, sagt hier, bla bla bla, fünf, keine
changes. Performance Update, kann ich sagen, yes, aber da passiert nichts. Fertig. Woran
sich den State merkt, ich dachte eigentlich hier, aber anscheinend ist es doch nicht so.
Dann weiß ich nicht, wo der State ist. Ich dachte eigentlich, dass der State auch hier
liegt. Dachte es ist wie bei Terraform. Der fragt die Google API ab, ja, aber der muss
ja einen State haben, wie es sein soll versus wie es ist. Aber vielleicht hat er es auch
schon hochgeladen. Das weiß ich gar nicht. Ja, das verwenden wir ja nicht. App.Pulumi.com,
das habe ich ja gesagt, das wollen wir nicht verwenden. Local, ja ja, es muss local auf
jeden Fall irgendwie sein, weil er ja gesagt hat, feil, vielleicht ist es im Heimatverzeichnis
irgendwo was. Hier. Da. Da ist das garantiert irgendwo drinnen. Hier, Logs. Irgendwo, irgendwo
hier wird das, ah, das sieht doch gut aus. Irgendwo hier ist der State. Aber es bietet
sich natürlich an, den vielleicht auch irgendwo zu hosten. Ja, also anscheinend ist der State
nicht im Verzeichnis, sondern irgendwo lokal. Also, wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Also genau,
das erste ist schon mal, also wir haben jetzt gesehen, wenn ich das Ganze noch mal ausführe,
weiß er ja, die Umgebung ist schon in dem State, wie sie sein soll und dementsprechend
macht er nichts. So und jetzt zur nächsten Frage, was mache ich denn jetzt, wenn ich
anstatt vier Acht-Kisten haben will? Naja, ganz einfach, wir müssen ihm sagen, dass wir
einen anderen State haben wollen. Wir müssen als Acht reinschreiben, zum Beispiel. Ich
mein, idealerweise hätte man vielleicht hier oben so paar globale Variablen definiert,
ja, keine Ahnung, Vm, oder Konst, Vm, Count oder irgendwie sowas, ja, Acht. Also idealerweise
hätte man irgendwie sowas, sowas gemacht, ja, dann müsste man das nämlich nur oben
anpassen, aber jetzt mal unabhängig davon, ja, sag ich einfach Acht und wenn ich das
jetzt noch mal ausführe, dann sagt er, aha, du willst in deinem State acht Vms haben,
aber du hast nur vier, also leg ich noch vier weitere an. Jetzt, guck hier, sagt er, aha,
wir brauchen jetzt auch noch Webapp 4, 5, 6, 7. Also er weiß sogar, dass es eins, zwei,
drei schon gibt von vorher, aber wir haben jetzt ja gesagt, wir wollen noch vier weitere,
also müssen das 4, 5, 6, 7 logischerweise sein. Performance Upgrade, yes. Und jetzt
wird man gleich sehen, wir haben auf einmal acht, acht Webapp-Kisten, da sind sie. Die
werden auch aufgebaut, so, und so funktioniert das. Das ist tatsächlich sehr nice und umso
komplexer das wird und umso komplizierter die Environments, die man hat, umso besser ist
es, was mit so einem Tool zu machen, anstatt von Hand. Bei einfachen Sachen, ja, oder beispielsweise
bei irgendwie drei Kisten oder so, klar, da kann ich im Prinzip das CLI-Tool verwenden
oder einen Bash-Skip machen, was mit das anlegen, das ist easy, das geht alles. Aber ich sag
mal, ab eigentlich schon einer kleineren, ab einer zweistelligen Anzahl von Kisten,
da mehr als zehn, weil da kommen ja oftmals noch Verwaltungs-Sachen dabei, noch ein Server
für Logging, noch irgendwas fürs Monitoring, noch DNS-Einträge, extra Storage-Platten,
irgendwelche Backup-Pläne, also zehn VMs sind es ja in der Regel nicht einfach nur
zehn VMs, sondern da hängt ja noch einiges mit dran. Vielleicht hat sogar noch einer
zusätzlich irgendwo einen Managed Kubernetes-Cluster, noch zusätzlich für andere Services. Und
dann hast du auf einmal relativ schnell 80, 90, 100, 200 einzelne Ressourcen, nicht VMs,
Ressourcen, also auch eine IP ist eine Ressource in dem Sinn, und managde die Dinger mal von
Hand und lösch da mal sinnvoll was und erstelle mal sinnvoll was neu und ändere mal was sinnvoll
dazu und den Überblick zu behalten. Also gerade für so was sind solche Tools wirklich richtig
nice und ich kann jedem nur empfehlen, der im Admin-Bereich, im DevOps-Bereich, aber auch
im Entwickler-Bereich unterwegs ist, sich solche Tools mal anzugucken. Das ist ein Test,
das ist ein Test für Google Cloud. Ich kann 300 Euro ausgeben, dann ist vorbei. Also wie
gesagt kann jedem empfehlen sich wirklich Terraform oder Pulumi, aber Terraform ist das verbreitetere
auf jeden Fall, mal anzugucken für Konfig, ein bisschen Ansible, aber gerade diese Provisioning-Sachen
mit Terraform und Pulumi ist wirklich eine richtig super Geschichte. So mal angenommen
meine Web-App ist jetzt wieder, brauche ich nicht mehr, da sieht man, der ist jetzt auch
so schlau, wenn ich jetzt sage Destroy, jetzt will der nicht etwa nur vier löschen, sondern
er weiß aha, ich habe ja eigentlich acht angelegt und hier einen zusätzlichen Stack,
das heißt du willst wenn schon, wenn du sagst, dieses Environment-Destroy soll ich vielleicht
alles löschen, also fliegt alles weg. Das ist wirklich coole Sache. Also ich kann euch
empfehlen, wenn ihr einsteigt neben Terraform, Terraform ist das verbreitetere System und
ich würde mal sagen auch das einsteigerfreundlichere System, weil ihr halt keine vollständige
Programmiersprache da beherrschen müsst dafür. Dafür finde ich, ist meine persönliche Meinung,
ich finde das ist gerade das coole an Pulumi, dass du eben eine vollständige Programmiersprache
drumherum hast. Ich meine ernsthaft, mach sowas hier mal in Terraform, mach mal das. Das
geht. Du oder in Enzible, in Enzible kannst du irgendwie each, each width sonst was machen
und in Terraform kannst du irgendwelche Dinger, Arrays, Klammern und so oder was umgedreht,
weiß ich gerade aus dem Kopf gar nicht mehr. Aber eine probliche Schleife, wo man sofort
erkennt aha, es gibt eine Schleife, ach Durchläufe und da drin wird eine VM angelegt und der
Name hochgezählt. Mach das hier mal in Terraform, das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Unter dem Strich machen die Tools natürlich was ähnliches, das läuft, am Ende kommt
irgendein State raus, der generiert wird in dieser State, wenn dann Applied auf den jeweiligen
Cloud-Anbieter und abgeglichen mit was da ist. Also es ist jetzt ja nicht so, dass das,
ach so, das sollte ich jetzt vielleicht an der Stelle nochmal sagen. Also es ist nicht
so, dass Pulumi einen Schleifendurchlauf macht, eine VM anlegt, dann den nächsten Schleifendurchlauf
macht und eine VM anlegt. Nein, nein, nein, nein, so ist das nicht. Pulumi führt das hier
am Anfang komplett aus, dann fällt dort ein State raus und erst dieser State wird angewendet
auf den Cloud-Anbieter. Also es ist nicht parallel zum Programmlauf, dass Sachen erzeugt
werden in der Cloud, sondern der Programmlauf passiert zuerst komplett und das State, der
da rausfällt aus diesem Programm, der wird dann darauf angewendet. Pulumi hat glaube
ich irgendeine Bridge für Terraform-Module, ja, habe ich aber noch nie verwendet. So,
jetzt machen wir mal weiter, also was können wir als nächstes machen? Startscript, wie
wäre es da mal mit einem Startscript, ach so, ja, okay, lass mal überlegen. Wir machen
mal wieder runter, komm, wir machen mal vor allem es. Hier, ach. Ach. Ach.
Irgendwie so. So, also was wir jetzt mal machen können ist, können versuchen, mal die Sachen
ein bisschen zu konfigurieren und jetzt sind wir bei dem Punkt, wo so die Überschneidungen
zwischen Ansible und diesen ganzen Provisioning-Tools anfangen. Ich habe jetzt ja einzig und allein
einen Linux-Server angelegt. Ich habe einen nackischen Linux-Server angelegt, eine kleine
Linux-VM mit Debian 11 drauf und sonst nix. Wenn ich diese Kisten jetzt konfigurieren
will, natürlich könnte ich dafür Ansible nehmen. Das heißt, ich professioniere die
Sachen über Pulumi und lasse danach Ansible laufen, aber ich kann auch kleine Miniskripte,
kann man hier direkt Cloud-Init drinne machen? Weiß ich nicht. Startup-Script, Metadata-Startup-Script
muss ich mal angucken, wie das geht. Ja, man kann auch kleine Startskripte laufen lassen,
um das zu machen. Jetzt gucken wir uns jetzt mal an, wie das jetzt funktioniert. ECP-Pulumi-Cloud-Init,
wie würde man die Cloud-Init ausführen lassen? Ich habe keinen Bock, heute noch was mit Ansible
dazu zu machen. Das lenkt auch vom eigentlichen ab. Ansible haben wir auch schon öfters mal
gemacht. Brauchst du das für die Arbeit? Wie kommst du dazu? Einfach, weil es mich
interessiert macht und weil ich mir für meinen neuen Job mal ein bisschen Google Cloud mehr
angucken will. Ist ja alles schon ein bisschen her. Debian hat gar kein Cloud-Init? Doch,
warum nicht? Ich wundere, wenn Debian, doch klar hat Debian Cloud-Init. Also, wie geht
das? Pulumi-Cloud-Init-Config. Ja, schön und wie war das? Wie verwendet man das jetzt?
ECP-Pulumi-Cloud-Init. Das ist eine gute Frage. Muss man das in Meta start schreiben? Pre-seed
heißt das. Sollen wir mal gucken, wo es das gibt. Cloud-Init. Das geht bestimmt irgendwo.
Kann man da überhaupt Cloud-Init angeben? How to use Cloud-Init?
Ach, ist das oder Debian wirklich nicht drauf?
Ja, gut, das müssen wir uns gleich mal ausprobieren. Werden wir mal in Custom Script. Hallo, ich
bin gerade erst dazu. Du benutzt C-Sharp, um in Google Cloud einen Server anzulegen, oder?
Naja, fast, fast. So ganz stimmt das nicht. Ich benutze ein Tool, das nennt sich Pulumi
und Pulumi kann unter anderem C-Sharp verwenden, um den State zu generieren, den es als Grundlage
nimmt, um Cloud-Resourcen anzulegen. Also, es ist nicht wirklich so, dass das.NET-Programm
das anlegt, das.NET-Programm generiert den State, was Pulumi dann in der Cloud anlegt.
Das ist quasi ein bisschen wie Terraform nur mit ordentlicher Programmiersprache. Okay,
schauen wir mal. Wie kann man hier Metadata? Metadata-Startup-Script. Guck mal hier, so
was da, so was will ich haben. Metadata-Startup-Script. Echo-Hi. Okay, das probieren wir mal aus,
ob das funktioniert. Allerdings, please nur eine VM, das reicht. Also, wir sollten jetzt
eine Datei bekommen unter slash, die test.txt heißt und wo Hi drin steht. Da bin ich mal
gespannt, ob das funktioniert. Pulumi ab. Super, super, super-secures, geheimes Passwort.
Yes, VM anlegen. User-Data hieß dieser Krempel. Das meine ich, User-Data, genau. Ja. Ja,
Metadata-Startup-Script. User-Data. Startup-Script. Alternative to using Startup-Meta-Key
expected. Okay, das haben sie irgendwie anders genannt. User-Data. Ja, da habe ich jetzt
keine Ahnung von. So, zumindest sollte da jetzt eine Kiste angelegt haben gleich. Mit
einer Datei, also der Muster Startup-Script ausgeführt haben. Gehen wir mal gucken, PSSH
drauf verbinden. Das H-Schlüssel wird generiert. So, und jetzt sollten wir unter slash einer
Datei test.txt liegen haben, die Hi heißt. Nicht Hi heißt, wo Hi drinne steht. Wenn das
funktioniert, ist schon mal super. Dann kann man schon ein bisschen was damit anfangen.
So, also gucken wir mal. CD slash, und da sollte es eine Datei test.txt geben. Test.txt. Und
da steht Hi drinne. Funktioniert. Sehr schön. Okay, also so kann man Startscripter ausführen.
Das ist schon mal praktisch. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt Ansible verwenden würde, würde
man hier wahrscheinlich einfach reinschreiben. Ansible Play. Was ist das? Ansible Play? Ansible
Playbook. Ansible Run. Ansible Playbook, genau. Könnte man dann hier reinschreiben. Hier
könnte man dann quasi Ansible ausführen. Oder halt irgendwelche Customs-Scripts. Erst
mal PIP Ansible. Ja, also was man hier zum Beispiel machen könnte, ist tatsächlich
sowas wie Update oder sowas. Genau, ich muss erst mal Update machen. Da sieht man jetzt,
was man an der Stelle auch schon sieht, ist, dass solche Tools wie Ansible halt für Konfiguration
einfach angenehmer sind. Ja, ich müsste jetzt hier zum Beispiel sowas machen hier. Wie macht
man Multiline? Ach so, ja gut. Haha Leute, wir können ein neues C Sharp Feature verwenden.
Komm mal, Update. Können wir jetzt machen. Zack. Update. Da bin ich mal gespannt, da bin
ich mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert jetzt. Multiline. Hier, Echo. Mal noch mal Echo 1,
2, 3 nach, egal, test.txt. Nächste Zeile. Machen wir jetzt Echo. Echo 1 und Echo 2.
Zack. Ob man es so Multiline schreiben kann, das wäre natürlich cool, wenn das funktioniert.
Volumi ab. Sollte jetzt erkennen, Startscript hat sich geändert, muss den Kram neu anlegen.
Hoffentlich checkt das dann auch. Merken wir uns jetzt mal hier hinten hat das Ding A58.
Replace, also er hat festgestellt, die VM gibt es, aber Startscript hat sich geändert.
Möchte ich das neu erstellen? Yes. Creating Replacement. Wie hält man solch eine Masse
an VMs mit Updates, etc. auf dem neuesten Stand oder legt ihr das Google? Ok, das kommt
darauf an, was du hast. Also bei VMs machen die das nicht automatisch. Was sich anbietet
ist, dass man zum Beispiel automatisch Updates installieren lässt, die keinen Reboot brauchen.
Also wenn man sowas wie Ubuntu oder Debian verwendet, ist das kein Problem, kann man
machen. Du schaltest auch so Updates an und sagst, hey bitte keinen Reboot machen, ja,
aber alle sonst, du kannst Updates machen, aber lass mal Kernel Updates aus. Das ist
schon relativ viel, was dann damit abgefangen wird, aber klar, wenn du das kontrolliert
machen willst, dann kannst du das auch über Ansible zum Beispiel machen. Oder aber die
einfachste Variante und simpelste Variante, gut, du lockst dich halt per SSH ein und machst
ein Update, machst eine Vorschleife mit SSH drin. Aber das ist tatsächlich, also wenn
du viele Kisten hast, du hast ein Inventory, wo du weißt, aha, diese 300 Kisten gibt es,
kannst du mit einem Ansible Playbook wunderbar ein Update machen oder Befehle ausführen
lassen. Und dann hast du nämlich auch, wenn du es gut gemacht hast, hast du dann auch
noch Tags da dran, dass du sagst, hey, ich lasse jetzt erstmal alle Entwicklungs-Kisten
oder alle Development-Kisten updaten, fange an mit Frontend-Server, dann Backend-Server,
dann Management-Systeme und das mache ich danach, mache ich das dann in Testing, danach
mache ich es noch in Live. Wenn du es richtig schön getaggt hast, dann geht das. Das ist
dann easy, dann brauchst du quasi einen Befehl, tauschst die Umgebung aus, zack, hast du auch
geupdatet. Oder ja, im Zweifelsfall, wenn da ein Inventory, wenn da irgendwo mal was
dazukommt, kannst du bei SSH drauf verbinden. Also ich würde zwei Sachen machen. Standardmäßig,
wenn du es möglichst wartungsfrei haben willst, nimm bei den Cloud-Kisten Auto-Updates. Fertig.
Nimmst Ubuntu, machst Auto-Updates, sagst dem halt hier keine Kernel-Updates und bitte
nicht neu starten, aber alles andere machen wir ab. Auto-Updates, easy. Passiert eigentlich
in der Regel auch gar nichts. So, alles andere musst du dir halt überlegen, wie du selbst
ausrollst. Muss man programmieren können, um Ansible zu lernen? Naja, ein bisschen so
die Logik ist da schon nicht verkehrt. Du musst keine Programmiersprache können. Ansible
selbst braucht ein installiertes Python auf dem Zielsystem, aber es schadet, wenn du Power
Shell kannst, kommst du mit Ansible easy klar. Es schadet auf jeden Fall nicht, wenn du ein
bisschen Source Code lesen kannst. So, also Replacement ist da. Guck, die Kiste heißt
jetzt anders, die Kiste heißt jetzt anders, da hat die alte Gelösche neu angelegt und
jetzt sollten wir eigentlich Test 1 und Test 2 haben, wenn das mit Multiline-Script so
funktioniert hat. Und wir haben Test 1 und Test 2. Hat funktioniert. Was natürlich sehr
cool ist, dass man das jetzt Multiline untereinander schreiben kann. Das geht übrigens erst in
Python, geht da schon seit 20 Jahren. In C Sharp geht es erst seit der letzten Version,
dass man Multiline Strings mit mehreren Anführungszeichen macht. Und wisst ihr was besonders cool ist?
Ihr könnt sogar String Interpolation da drin machen, ich zeig euch mal was. Es ist jetzt
ein C Sharp Feature, was es erst seit, wie gesagt, seit letzter Version gibt. Oder hier
wollen wir Jason String anlegen. Ihr habt hier noch ein paar Variablen, hier blub, gleich
eins und was auch immer. Ihr wollt jetzt ein Jason Objekt oder ein Jason String anlegen.
Normalerweise würde ihr dann sowas hier machen. So was. Ah, der ist so schlau und erkennt,
dass das nie ausgeführt wird. Ich könnte sowas machen wie Jason String, dann sowas
wie hier. Cute Chat. Das ist ein Jason Objekt. Jason, nachher du bringst kein abschließendes
Ding zu machen. Pog15 oder so. Das ist ein Jason Objekt. Was ist denn jetzt, wenn ich
beispielsweise das aus dieser Variable hier unten einsetzen will? Wie gesagt, Neues C
Sharp Feature seit letzter Version. Geht ja nicht so. Ich kann jetzt ja hier nicht noch
mal sowas hier schreiben. Das funktioniert ja nicht, weil da ist kein String Interpolation
an der Stelle. Jetzt könnte ich natürlich sagen, ja gut, ich schalte String Interpolation
einfach an, indem ich da ein Ausrufezeichen davor mache. Äh, keine Ausrufe, einen Dollar
davor mache. Das geht aber nicht, weil ja Jason selbst, halt Klammer auf Klammer zu
brauche, dass es ein gültiges Jason Objekt ist. Das heißt, was mein ich jetzt? Ganz einfach,
ich mache zwei Dollarzeichen davor und escape dann auch mit zwei offenen Klammern und jetzt
funktioniert das. Also die Anzahl der Dollarzeichen muss die Anzahl der öffnenen Klammern sein,
wo ich was einsetzen will. Was den Vorteil hat, ich kann eigentlich so gut wie nie Konflikte
bekommen, wenn ich es ordentlich mache. Das habe ich so noch in keiner anderen Sprache
gesehen. Das finde ich eine wirklich gut durchdachte Lösung. Weil es gibt so Sachen
wie, gut, lässt String Interpolation raus oder machst String, machst irgendwie zusammen
mit einem Plus. Aber so kannst du, solange du weißt, dass dein Input keine fünf aufeinander
folgenden offenen Klammern haben will. Jaja, das geht, das geht theoretisch auch so. Theoretisch,
ich habe jetzt nicht gezählt, wie viele das sind, aber das geht, das geht theoretisch mit
beliebig vielen. Also wenn du acht brauchst oder so, dann kannst du das machen. Und das
gibt es jetzt seit C-Sharp 11, das ist ein neues Feature. Sowohl, dass es String Literals
gibt, mehrere Zeilen, aber auch die String Interpolation mit unterschiedlich vielen
geschweiften Klammern auf. Eigentlich eine richtig clevere Idee, muss man an der Stelle
echt mal sagen. Also ich finde, Microsoft baut vieles sinnvoller ein. Es gibt in C-Sharp
viele Änderungen, wo ich mir denke, muss das sein? Default Interfaces, sowas zum Beispiel.
Ich gette, warum sie es gemacht haben, gerade ihre eigenen Office-APs halt, aber so ein
paar Sachen, wo ich mich frage, ja, da haben wir jetzt nicht wirklich gebraucht, aber die
machen auch viele sinnvolle Sachen. Kann man nichts sagen, also wirklich, die.NET-Entwicklung
ist top. Also ich mag auch das.NET Ökosystem und dass es jedes Jahr eine neue Version gibt
und sowas. So, wo sind wir jetzt stehen geblieben? Also wir können Metadata Startup Script, also
wir können Firmen aufbauen, wir können Start-Skripte ausführen. Die bringen uns jetzt natürlich
nicht allzu viel an der Stelle. Aber ich glaube, man kann sich gut vorstellen, hier könnte
man auch was Sinnvolles machen, ja, Package-Updates oder sowas. Oder halt Cloud-Init ausführen
und eine Datei hinlegen, also könnte man zum Beispiel Ubuntu nehmen. Ja, wir können jetzt
zum Beispiel dann, hey, wir wollen nicht Ubuntu, wir wollen, was haben die eigentlich für?
Was? Okay, da muss ich mal kurz gucken. ECP-Images-Ubuntu, was haben die für Ubuntu, welche Images kann
man verwenden? Images, geht das in JavaScript nicht noch einfacher? JavaScript String Interpolation,
JavaScript String Interpolation ist das hier, oder? Kekl. Und dann so? Geht das in JavaScript?
Ach, ich weiß es aus dem Kopf gar nicht, wie es in JavaScript geht. Öffentliche Images,
Ubuntu, ne, zur Seite Images, ja, was? Ernsthaft, muss ich das jetzt, muss ich dazu angemeldet
sein? Öffentliche Images, ja, Seite zu Images, okay, gut. Welche Images gibt's? Google,
zeig's mir. Ich will Images haben. Ubuntu, ne. Deep Learning? What? Ich will stinknormale
Ubuntu-Image haben. Ja, Ubuntu 2204 will ich haben. Das da zum Beispiel, ja, genau. Minimal,
okay, was haben wir, was haben wir zu bieten? Was ist denn Ubuntu Pro Fips? Was ist Ubuntu
Pro Fips? Was? Okay, keine Ahnung. Ich will Ubuntu 2204 haben, 2204. Und zwar x86, jawoll.
Muss man da wirklich ne Version angeben, die ich haben will? Kann ich einfach sagen, ich
will die latest aktuell und die letzte released. Und wie gebe ich das jetzt an, Demian Cloud?
Wie? Wie bin ich jetzt überfragt, wie man das da ordentlich, ordentlich reinschreibt?
Lass uns mal angucken, wie man da Ubuntu installiert. Creating Ubuntu 22 template. Ne, ich will
kein template. Jammy. Na ja, alles klar. How to deploy Ubuntu for minstance. Ja, genau.
Jammy 22. Was? Ubuntu US Cloud 22. Okay, okay, 22. Okay, also im Prinzip müsste ich da sowas
reinschreiben. Ubuntu US Cloud Ubuntu 2204 LTS. Okay, bin ich mal gespannt. Er sollte
es ja eigentlich jetzt recreate, weil er sagt Moment falsches Betriebssystem. Replace, jawoll.
Okay, er sollte aus dem Demian jetzt Ubuntu machen. Sicher, dass das Ubuntu ist. Nein,
das ist nicht Ubuntu. Ubuntu ist das. Nur, nur so richtig ausgesprochen. Deleting. Okay,
das funktioniert. So, jetzt probieren wir mal ein bisschen, jetzt probieren wir mal
ein bisschen was advanced. Jetzt haben wir genug VMs angelegt. Wir versuchen jetzt mal.
Keine Ahnung, was können wir an? Netzwerk, Netzwerk anzulegen. Firewall. Hast du dein
Feature in die Werkstatt gebracht? Jaja, der ist auch schon wieder da und schon wieder
funktioniert schon wieder. Also Firewall, Netzwerk und dann machen wir einfach. Komm, wir machen
das so. Easy, Leute. Ich weiß, wie wir das machen. Wir machen eine Firewall, Port 80
und Hello World. Hello World Web Server starten wir da drauf. Hier, im Startup Script. Im
Startup Script starten wir einen Web Server. Hello World. Irgendwas. Wir probieren noch
was. Komm ich von den Dingern überhaupt ins Internet, um da Updates zu machen? Updates.
Das, das, das probieren wir jetzt mal. Das müssen wir uns mal ausbringen. Also so komme
ich höchstwahrscheinlich nicht ins Internet, gehe ich mal von aus, weil die haben ja keine
öffentlichen IPs und auch keine, kein NAT Gateway und nix. Also hier haben wir die Kiste,
da müsste jetzt Ubuntu drauf sein, wenn das richtig funktioniert hat. Naja, wir gucken,
wir gucken jetzt mal, wir gucken, ob das funktioniert. Wir pingen jetzt mal, pingen mal Google. Das
wird wahrscheinlich schon nicht funktionieren oder 8888 oder 1111. Hat er die Fault nicht
NAT? Ich habe keine Ahnung aus dem Kopf, weiß ich nicht. Müssen wir mal ausprobieren
jetzt. Sehen wir gleich. So, ping 8.8.8.8.8. Nope, hat er nicht. Gibt kein NAT. Dementsprechend
wird wahrscheinlich auch kein Update funktionieren. Nopos. Aber ein Cloudinit hätten wir. Ok,
also könnte ich da auch gleich ein Cloudinit drauf ausführen. Das werde ich mir mal merken.
UpMirror erreichbar? Ne, anscheinend nicht. Er geht ja schon hier auf irgendeinem Europe
West Archiv. Also das scheint gar nicht zu funktionieren. Ich gehe mal davon aus, da
muss ich jetzt ein Netzwerk erstellen mit NAT und alle möglichen Sachen. Wundert mich
aber eigentlich, dass es zumindest mal eine Verbindung intern hat. Aber gut, geht halt
nicht. Guck mal, Routing, IPRow. Nö. Nö, gibt es nichts. Nix. Kommt nicht nach außen.
Dann legen wir jetzt mal ein Netzwerk an. Da habe ich vorhin was gefunden, wie das funktioniert.
GCP? Web Server. Da habe ich vorhin eben ein Beispiel gefunden. Web Server Virtual Machine
Instance und GCE. Genau. Die machen es mit JavaScript, was aber kein großartiges Problem
ist. Wir können das einfach übersetzen in C-Sharp. Der Code ist ja relativ ähnlich.
Also wir brauchen ein Netzwerk dafür erstmal. Ok, Netzwerk. Alle VMs kommen an das gleiche
Netzwerk. Das heißt, die VMs können schon mal untereinander reden. Also var, Netzwerk,
und Netzwerk heißt ja, internal oder so. Ok, Netzwerk, dann brauchen wir eine Firewall.
Das ist quasi, dass man von außen drauf zugreifen kann. Da kann ich jetzt einstellen, was ich
freigeben will nach außen hin. Also nicht nach außen hin, von außen. Also, var, Firewall,
gleich Firewall, die wir inbound oder so nennen. So. New. Und jetzt geht das so schon mal nett,
alles klar. Äh, was muss ich jetzt hier reinschreiben? What? Ach, New habe ich vergessen.
Ok, New, Firewall, args. Netzwerk. Ok, da brauchen wir jetzt Netzwerk.id, stand da,
Netzwerk.id, das machen wir auch. Netzwerk.id. Und dann ist, allows, New. Ok, was wollen
wir jetzt? Protokoll, TCP, Port 22. Ne, eigentlich gar nichts. Wir wollen ja nur outbauen erstmal,
inbauen. Ja komm, komm, komm, wir machen SSH. Wir geben SSH frei, das ist auch ok.
So, allows, New. Jetzt ist die Frage, wie man das überhaupt schreibt. New. So. Jetzt
habe ich keine Ahnung, wie man das... Kein Plan. Müssen wir mal, da muss ich mal die
Hilfe gucken. Firewall. GCP, Compute, Firewall, C-Sharp. Ne, nicht G. GCP. Meine Güte, Alter,
ich kann das nicht mehr schreiben. Hier. So, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, wie das funktioniert.
Basic Usage, Default Firewall, bla bla bla, New. Netzwerk, haben wir, allows. Ok. Aber
doch allows, New, New GCP, Compute, Input. Ach du Scheiße man, da wäre ich ja im Leben
nicht drauf gekommen. Firewall, allowed args, Protokoll, TCP, TCP, Portokolls, Ports. Ports
80. Ok und 22, alles klar. Aber was war so? Das ist jetzt Input, das ist jetzt inbound
quasi. Da sollen wir mal... By the way, warum ist das hier nicht typisiert auf Int? Warum
muss ich da Strings verwenden für Ports? Warum nehmen die nicht einfach... Und das muss
ja kein Int sein, das könnte ja ein Int 16 sein, da kannst du noch nicht mal was Falsches
reinschreiben. Aber das wäre natürlich deutlich schöner. So, Firewall. Wegen Ranges. Das
könnte man aber auch anders machen. Könnte man noch Ranges start, Ranges end oder so.
So, Network Interfaces, das muss ich jetzt anders machen. Was ist das denn? Source, Tag,
keine Ahnung, brauchen wir nicht. Network und da schreibe ich jetzt dort Default inschreibe
ich da Network ID. Wahrscheinlich mache ich sowas hier. Network ID. Name or self link
of the network to attach. Oder muss ich da sowas reinschreiben? Nee, geht nicht. Wahrscheinlich
so. Wahrscheinlich so. Network ID. Ok. Ja, probieren wir das mal aus. Pull me up. Wahrscheinlich
meckert er jetzt. Oh, oh, was jetzt? Was? One Error occured. Source Tags, Source Range
or Source Service Accounts? Source. Source Ranges. Firewall will apply only to traffic that has
Source IP address in these ranges. Only IPv4 is supported. Wo wir wieder dabei sind, weil
ich letztens gesagt habe, IPv6 mäßig werden wir in nächster Zeit da nicht, sich nicht
komplett durchsetzen sehen. Da war der Chat ja anderer Meinung, aber ich stehe da immer
noch dahinter zu dem, was ich gesagt habe. Ich glaube nicht, dass wir das in nächster
Zeit sehen werden. Und bevor sich IPv6 hundertprozentig usable durchgesetzt hat, hat Google irgendwas
eigenes gemacht. Irgendwas IPv4 Extended mit ganz abartigen Verbiegungen von IPv4, so nach
dem Motto, es sind die hinteren zwei Bytes an der Stelle auf eins, dann gibt es irgendwie
noch zusätzlich encoded im ersten Byte noch 20 weitere IPs und was auch immer. Die werden
irgendwie IPv4 aufbohren oder so was, bis sich IPv6 auch durchgesetzt hat. Wahrscheinlich
wird sich dementsprechend nie was durchsetzen. Solang Microsoft, Google, Amazon und da alle
an einem Strang ziehen, gibt es dann irgendwas anderes. Network Ranges. Wie gibt es das
jetzt an? Source. Kann man jetzt einfach sowas hier machen? Programmiert ihr eine eigene
Firewall für Linux? Ne, wir legen Google Cloud Ressourcen an. Wir legen vier VMs in Google
Cloud an mit einer Firewall davor, die nur Traffic auf Port 80 und 22 erlaubt, dass man
darauf dann von außen zugreifen kann. Hab ich mich vertippt? Ach ne, Punkt Null, du hast
recht nicht Slash 24, Blödsinn. Slash Null, ja. So, jetzt mal gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Leute, ihr kommt übrigens nie auf meine Secret Pass Phrase. Ratet mal, was könnte meine
Secret Pass Phrase sein dafür? Kommt ihr nie drauf. Update, yes. Chat, ihr seid fast
richtig. Ne, ne, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, ist schon richtig. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, richtig. Super
geheim, ne? Kommt nie einer drauf. Aber wie kann ein Best Practice Passwort schlecht sein?
Ansonsten versucht man seine ganzen Sachen nach Best Practices aufzubauen, aber bei
Passwort dann nicht. Das ergibt doch keinen Sinn. Wie kann ein Passwort schlecht sein,
wenn es 60.000 andere Leute verwenden? Ich meine, so viele Benutzer können ja lügen
nicht, ja. Wenn man ein Passwort 60.000 Mal verwendet, wieder muss das gut sein. Updating
failed. Oh, da hat er Probleme mit. Ja, das mag er nicht. Das mag er wahrscheinlich nicht,
weil das vorher ein anderes Netzwerk hatte. One unchanged. Warum? Changing machine type
requires to stop it. To acknowledge this, please set allow stop for update gleich true
in your config. Von welcher config spricht er jetzt? Hier? Config? Ne. Ne, oder? Von
welcher config redet der hier denn? Ach, hier in der Instance, oder wie in der Instance?
Ah, ach so, da drinne. Jetzt muss das, jetzt muss das checken. Do you want to perform this
update? Yes, will ich. Neues Netzwerk Interface, blitz, blitz neues Netzwerk Interface. Bei
Min.io und generell S3 gibt es ja automatische Server-seitige Verschlüsselung. Ich verstehe
nur den, was nur nicht den Sinn dahinter. Ich habe keine Ahnung, das habe ich mir noch
nicht angeguckt. Aber Server-seitige Verschlüsselung klingt jetzt erstmal, also je nachdem, wenn
der Server auch das Passwort kennt, immer in der config oder so, dass du es beim Start
nicht eingeben musst, erscheint mir jetzt irgendwie unsinnig, aber ich kenne jetzt
den Anwendungsfall nicht. Also was es gibt ist, dass das verschlüsselt wird, aber du
beim Neustart dann ein Passwort initial einmal eingeben musst. Oh man, wo ist das Problem?
Sub-Network does not belong to the network. Invalid. Alles klar Leute, jetzt wird es nicht
bescheid. Lul. Was möchte er mir sagen? Invalid value for field resource. Network? Sub-Network
does not belong to network. What? Habe ich irgendwas falsch gemacht? Glaub nicht, oder?
Sieht doch eigentlich sinnvoll aus, was ich da gebaut habe. Ok, wisst ihr was? Ich lösche
das Ding jetzt einfach. Yes. Und dann legen wir es nochmal neu. Guck mal, ob es funktioniert.
Ja, das sind dann halt so die Tücken von den ehemaligen Cloud-Anbietern, wo man gucken
muss, was, wie wollen sie es denn haben. So, was können wir noch sinniger machen? Also
mal angenommen, das funktioniert jetzt gleich. Dann haben wir VMS angelegt, wir müssen nach
Startup-Scripts funktionieren. Netzwerk, eh Netzwerk-Configs. Ja, wir starten dann
irgendwann Mini-Mini-Web-Server drauf. Nginx, wir starten Nginx, wir installieren, wenn
das gehen sollte, installieren wir den Nginx und gucken uns das Hello World von außen
an. Ach ja, wie bekomme ich denn dann überhaupt die NAT-IP raus von dem Krempel? Instance,
Firewall. Ja, wie machen die das denn hier? Ah, guck mal. Export, Instance, Name. Alter,
was ist das? Was bin ich denn hier sehend? Was ist das? Compute, what? Compute Instance,
Network-Interfaces-Apply, Netzwerk-Interfaces, Null-Axis-Config, NAT-IP. Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Das soll der Weg sein, wie ich die externe IP von meinem Interface rauskriege? Das ist
doch lächerlich, das ist also, das kann doch nicht sein. Das sieht in C++ schöner aus,
wirklich, ist echt so. Und das heißt schon was, wenn was in C++ hübscher aussieht. Das
ist in der Regel eigentlich kein Hinweis für das, was gut gemacht ist, wenn was in C++
hübscher aussieht. Also das ist jetzt nicht so, das gefällt mir nicht hier.
So, mal gucken, ob das Anlegen jetzt funktioniert. Schauen wir mal, ob er hier schon was angelegt
hat. Wo ist er an der Ball gerade? Ah, der ist gerade noch beim Network, was angelegt
wird. Okay. Also Skillkiller, ich kann ja aus Erfahrung dazu gar nichts sagen. Aber vielleicht
der Chat, wir wissen ja, der Chat ist high IQ, das haben auch viele Leute schon reingesubbt,
da ist der IQ natürlich noch mal ein bisschen weiter gestiegen. Guck grad mal nach den Subs,
nicht, dass ich wieder was vergessen hab. Hier, Clashcrafter, Dankeschön für den Sub.
One Run Dead, Sobati, Karlsson. Dankeschön Leute für den Sub. Für die Subs gar nicht
gesehen. Aja ja für Subscriptions. Und jetzt alle Weeps wieder out. So, sieht man jetzt,
ob das irgendwie von außen erreichbar ist. Ich bin blind Leute, ich muss hier auch noch
einen Darkreader installieren. Hat, hat, hat, hat Dings, hat Google Cloud einen Darkmode?
Geht das? Darkmode? Hat das einen Darkmode? Ne. Da gibt's nur Darkreader oder sowas. Ja,
das ist wahrscheinlich Darkreader. Brauchen wir nicht. Also wir haben vor allem, wir haben
eine interne IP, okay. Und können wir jetzt, können wir daraus jetzt ins Internet zugreifen?
Das wäre jetzt natürlich die Frage, ob das jetzt funktioniert hat hier mit meiner Firewall
und Network und Zeug dazwischen. Auf Google. Ja, Ping, 8.8.8, Nope. Funktioniert nicht.
Leute, mein Netzwerk-Config hat nicht funktioniert. Update. Was hab ich falsch gemacht? IP, ne,
das sieht immer noch ziemlich verkehrt aus. Okay. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, was ich verkehrt
gemacht hab. Was kann ich hier? Die Frage ist, ist es ID oder ist es Name?
Das ist jetzt die Frage. Ich hab bestimmt was in der Netzwerk-Config falsch gemacht.
Wie macht man das jetzt richtig? Okay. Wir suchen mal nach, wie wir das in Terraform machen.
ICP Terraform. Or M-Network. External Access oder so. IP-Access-Type. Access-Type? Ne.
Network. Network-Interface. Kennt sich jemand so gut mit Google Cloud aus? Ja ne, ich will
keine external IP. Ich will keine external IP, aber ich will ein NAT. External NAT.
Cloud-Instance. Instance NAT. Router NAT. Oh, jetzt wird's aber advanced, yes. To get
to network. Ah, muss ich dort angeben? Okay, jetzt blick ich nicht mehr durch. Ich muss
was angeben? Sub-Network? Router? What? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Das kann nicht
sein, oder? What the hell? Was? Das? Ne, das kann nicht sein. Ja, ich hätte auch gedacht,
der Gateway passt einfach. Ne, das kann ja nicht sein. Okay, okay. Instance Internet
Access. Network. Building Internet Connectivity for Private VMs. Alles klar. Boah, das ist
super. Okay, wie geht das? Von einer Form über Cloud NAT eine Verbindung zu einem externen
im Haus. Ja, genau, das will ich machen. Cloud NAT. What the fuck? Ah, das ist ja Massive
Fire IQ wieder. Die haben das hier im Beispiel. Im Beispiel ist das total einfach. Guck mal,
die legen hier, die legen hier eine Instance an, sagen Network ID. Im Prinzip das, was
ich ja auch mit einer Firewall davor. Network, Network, Access. Ah, ah, access config must
include a single empty config to request, was auch immer. Was für ein Ding? Flüchtetemporäre
IP. Aha, meine Güte. Magic Alter, Magic. Wo soll man das denn wissen, bitteschön?
Access configs? Und jetzt? Leeres, leeres Array oder wie? Was braucht es da bitteschön?
New Input List. MonkaS, man. Was? Was will er, dass ich da eintrage? Okay, ja args, aber
wie, wie, wie, wie soll man da eintragen? Ja, da müssen wir mal die Hilfe gucken. Args,
ja die, guck mal, guck mal Leute, das ist kaputt. Guck mal, das Ex, das Example ist
broken. No best type found. Was für ein Type ist es denn? Instance, network, access config.
Das ist wirklich weird, weird champ. Nee, meine Güte, Alter. Wie soll man das denn
funktionieren? Was haben die hier oben eingebunden? Nix sonst. Compute Inputs. Aha, okay. Wie jetzt
funktioniert das oder was? Wait a minute, warum hat das vorher nicht funktioniert? Weil er
nicht weiß, was es sein soll oder wie? Na gut, null, geht nicht. Also die DoCo erscheint
mir etwas weird champ an der Stelle. Ja, frag mal chat GPT, das weiß das bestimmt. Okay,
schauen wir mal. Access config, wo er weiß, dass es nullable sein soll, weiß er überhaupt
nicht. Nur weil er da kein Fragezeichen dran gemacht hat. Google ist wahrscheinlich einfach
wurscht. Okay, also probieren wir es nochmal. Also wir brauchen tatsächlich einen Eintrag,
dass er eine externe IP requestet oder eine temporäre IP requestet. Gucken wir mal, was
jetzt passiert, man. Instance Firewall. Meine Güte, Alter. Da müssen wir mal Stack Overflow
machen. Wie ist diese andere Krämpel? Access configs. Okay, das ist so advanced, dazu gibt
es schlicht und ergreifend gar nichts. So, mal schauen, was jetzt ist. Das erfordert
schon wieder wirklich Next Level Brain hier. Haben wir jetzt eine externe IP? Leute, seriously,
wie soll man da drauf kommen, dass das dafür erforderlich ist, dass er sich eine temporäre
externe IP holt? Was zum Teufel? Wer hat sich das, Alter. Wer macht bei Google nochmal
die ganzen C Sharp Bindings? Ist das nicht John Skeet? Ist John Skeet nicht der super
Five Head Typ von Stack Overflow, der die meisten Sterne hat dort? Warum programmiert
John Skeet sowas? Was ist das? Wie soll man darauf kommen, dass das dafür erforderlich
ist, dass man eine externe IP bekommt? What the fuck? Wer hat sich das ausgedacht? Ich
meine, nichts davon sieht nach externer IP aus, aber man muss es eintreiben, dass man
eine externe IP bekommt. Alles klar, klingt logisch. Was ist denn Schmachsinn, man? Google-Logik.
Stimmt, das ist ja Puluvi, das ist ja nicht mal John Skeet. Der hat ja damit gar nichts
zu tun, ja. Aber das andere Zeug anscheinend auch. Das muss ja wohl angelegt werden, auch
wenn du es so über Google anlegst. Ist Obvious. Ja, Chat, Obvious. Completely Obvious hier
an der Stelle. Nee, das ist nicht Senior Level, das ist schon Expert Architect Level hier.
Architekt Export Level. Ping, 8.8.8. Hey, Leute, es funktioniert. Update, jawoll. Zack, bumm.
Excellent, excellent. Funst. So, jetzt können wir das nämlich machen, was ich machen wollte
und zwar. Ja, also wir machen jetzt mal folgendes. Wir lassen das so, wir machen jetzt unser
Startscript. Sagen wir, okay. Upgrade minus Y muss man glaube ich. Oder glaubt man, man
kann sogar Dist Upgrade minus Y sagen. Nee. Ah nee, Upgrade gibt's ja nicht. Upgrade
minus Y reicht. Ja. Up, Upgrade minus Y sagen wir jetzt. Und dann. Up, install, nginx. Habe
ich das richtig geschrieben? Ich kann nginx ja mal nicht richtig schreiben. So, und das
sollte jetzt funktionieren. Jaja, alles. Stimmt, vorher sollen wir noch ein Update machen.
So, das könnte man übrigens auch alles über, wobei ich gar nicht weiß, ob man das über
Cloudinit machen kann. Ah, siehst du mal, Sixhead-Time, genau das habe ich gesagt,
dass er nicht, dass er nicht rumnervt und sagt, man kann hier nix. Jaja, genau. Debian
Frontend Non Interactive, Up, Dist, Upgrade, Minus, Minus, Yes. Genau das, Minus, Y hier.
So. Genauso wollte ich das sagen. Up, install, nginx. Yes. So, Chat, und wenn man jetzt
darauf geht, theoretisch, sollte da ein Hallo Welt nginx kommen, oder? Kommt dann halt
ein Hallo Welt nginx? Da kommt ein Hallo Welt nginx, Pog. Nice. Ok, dann schauen wir mal,
ob das jetzt alles so funktioniert, wie ich mir das gedacht habe. Destroy. Yes. Gut,
also. Heißt, wir haben eine Kiste, eine aktuell. So, es gibt eine Firewall, Port 80, Port 22.
Können wir dann gleich mal checken, ob Port 22 auch offen ist. So, wir sagen jetzt Web,
App, Count. Wir haben so eine super Anwendung, die kommt so geil an. Wir wollen jetzt 24,
24. Ey, das mit Load Balancer schaffe ich heute geistig nicht mehr. Da müssen wir das
nginx mal weitermachen. Da muss ein Load Balancer davor, da muss DNS-Einträge für erstellt
werden. Das probieren wir alles noch aus. Das probieren wir alles noch aus, Leute. Das
machen wir wahrscheinlich morgen dann. Probieren wir alles aus. Wenn DNS-Einträge, sonst wie.
Und dann wird CAC WSS-Service drauf deployed. Also, CAC WSS-Service. Unsere Testanwendung
wird dann drauf deployed. Pass auf mit deinen 300 Euro. Wieso? Ich hab die Verämpfung nur
ein paar Minuten an. Da passiert doch nix. So, 24 Kisten. Also, wir legen ein Netzwerk
an, wir legen eine Firewall an, Port 80, 22, 24 VMs. Ubuntu, machen einen Upgrade drauf
und dann installieren wir nginx. So, und wenn das jetzt funktioniert, haben wir danach 24
VMs, die alle die nginx, die Fall-Seite ausliefern. Und nächstes Mal probieren wir wirklich Load
Balancer, CAC WSS-Service drauf deployen. Und zwar hier, ich mach mir mein To-Do. Wir
könnten auch mal checken, dass man das an der Stelle vielleicht besser mit Ansible macht.
Load Balancer mit Hello World, nginx. Ja, können wir auch machen. Dann mach ich auch
keine Domains. Aber mit Domains ist das schöner. Ich hab ja nämlich extra CAC W.Services.
LB, Zertifikate, DNS und sowas. Das gucken wir uns das nächste Mal alles an, weil das
gehört ja letztendlich dazu, wenn man sowas betreiben will. So, alles weg hier. Nice.
So, und jetzt, bam, 24 VMs mit nginx, die Fall-Seite. Aber vorher Betriebssystem auf
einen aktuellen Stand bringen. Cloudinit können wir dann auch noch Auto-Updates machen.
Ja, aber Cloudinit einschalten. Ja, ja, ja. Yes. Oh, das flutscht, Leute, hier. 24 VMs.
Überlegt euch mal, jetzt sieht man auch einen weiteren Vorteil von diesen Tools, überlegt
euch mal, wie lange hättet ihr jetzt rumgemacht, das von Hand zu erzeugen, selbst über CLI,
weil ihr müsstet euch ja danach dann auch überall einloggen, Updates machen, nginx
installieren, selbst damit werdet ihr jetzt wahrscheinlich ne Stunde beschäftigt. Selbst
mit nem Bash, mit ner Vorschleife. Du läufst die Limits. Ah, hat der Free-Account Limit
VMLimit? Werden wir gleich sehen. Wird der wahrscheinlich gleich meckern. Schauen wir
mal, ob das funktioniert. 24 VMs anlegen. Oh, easy. Leute, kein Problem. 24 VMs. Bam.
Oh. Ah, Address Exceeded. Ja, okay, okay, okay, okay. Wir können nur eins, zwei, drei,
vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht. Ja, acht. Zehn Stück. Okay, mit acht Stück dürfen wir
maximal anlegen. Mehr IP-Adressen, mehr temporäre IPv4 darf ich anscheinend erstmal nicht bekommen.
Ja, okay. Brauchen wir dann auch später nicht, weil wir über unseren eigenen Loadbalancer
rausgehen oder über irgendeinen eigenen Gateway. Müssen wir ja auch. Die Dinger sollen ja
gar keine temporäre externe IPs bekommen. Okay, also anscheinend haben wir hier wirklich
Limit. Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht. Ja, acht. Acht externe, temporäre
externe IPs ist mit meinem Free-Account das Limit. Na gut. Der hat jetzt aber nicht alles
gelöscht, oder? Ich hab jetzt hier temporär irgendwelche VMs hängen. Ah, jetzt hat er
es kapiert. Was passiert, wenn du Polymer mit acht Instanzes machst und dann auch vier
in die Config machst, dann wieder Polymer überlöscht? Ja, dann löscht er vier übriggebliebene.
Also vier, die zu viel sind. Das stimmt, du hast recht. Du hast recht, wir können vielleicht
mehrere weltweit verteilen. Ach ja, by the way, das ist auch noch was, was wir machen
könnten. Das muss ja auch nicht alles und das ist auch das Schöne, was man jetzt mit
einer kompletten Programmiersprache machen kann. Wir könnten tatsächlich den Kram aufteilen
auf Europe West oder aber auch auf, was gibt es denn sonst noch so hier, ECB Zonen, US West,
zum Beispiel noch. Können wir zum Beispiel, können wir zum Beispiel das denn hier aus
wechseln lassen. Jede zweite Kiste, jede zweite Kiste, sowas. Können wir, könnte
man machen. Können wir, können wir zum Beispiel. Ok, das ist jetzt wirklich eklig. Also wir
könnten zum Beispiel sagen i durch zwei. Jede gerade Kiste, Europa, jede ungerade Kiste,
US West. Das würde ich normalerweise nicht so machen. Würde vielleicht zwei Schleifen
machen, einen für die Amis und einen für uns. Musst du das selber kauen oder kannst
du das automatisch georennen und dann anlegen lassen? Das geht wahrscheinlich auch, ja,
ich könnte wahrscheinlich irgendwie Replikas oder Redundancy oder irgendwas einstellen.
Wobei ich nicht weiß, wie es bei GCP mit den VMs ist. Also bei Azure geht das, bei
Azure kannst du einstellen Rec, RZ und Geo oder sowas. Sag mal, wie lang brauchst du
dafür zum löschen? Ah, hat er gelöscht, alles weg. So, ok, also dann gucken wir uns
jetzt mal an, was hier passiert. Also acht Kisten legen wir an. Ab. Jeweils abwechselns
EU und NA. Yes. So und dann verringern wir die von vier. Dann ist halt die Frage, nimmt
er die ersten vier weg oder die zweiten vier? Das müssen wir mal schauen. Was ist das eigentlich
für exquisite Musik im Hinterkonto? Das stimuliert den IQ. Und Prime Subs auch. So, hat er jetzt
angelegt. Nö, hat er noch keinen Bock gehabt. 40 Sekunden sind nicht schnell genug, sind
nicht genug Zeit, um Netzwerk anzulegen. Verstehe, verstehe. Jetzt kommen die VMs. Da sind sie.
Fünf Stück schon. Ja, eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf. Acht Stück, guck mal. Abwechseln.
Europe West, US West, Europe West, US West. Jetzt, ok, jetzt ist er fertig, hat alles
funktioniert. VMs sind created. Und schauen wir mal Leute, noch ist kein Nginx drauf,
aber es läuft im Hintergrund gerade. Können wir mal gucken, im Hintergrund läuft gerade
eine Update, falls das hier funktioniert, was ich da gemacht habe. Auf, log dich ein,
du Freige. Hardtop. Ja, DPKG, der macht im Hintergrund gerade Package Updates. Ja, macht
es. Disk Upgrade, fertig. Nginx install. Das ist SSH übers Webinterface von Google Cloud.
Du kannst doch über das Google CLI Tool oder wenn du Port 22 weiterleitest auch direkt
auf die Kisten drauf. Ok, jetzt müsste er fertig sein. Und jetzt, zack, haben wir ein
Nginx drauf. Ok, also wir haben jetzt acht Kisten mit Web Server provisioniert. Jeweils
vier Stück US, vier Stück EU. Ey, Pulumi muss gar nicht auf die Kiste drauf. Pulumi
geht über die Google API. Und sagt ja, was sie machen soll. Das heißt, die können ja
auch nur Sachen machen, die Google supportet. So, und jetzt sollte ich ja mal ausbrechen.
Was passiert, wenn wir von acht auf vier runtergehen? Welche erlöscht? Massive Deployment, ja,
richtig. Sixthead. Und erlöscht sieben, also vier, fünf, sechs, sieben würde erlöschen.
Wenn man runtergeht von acht auf vier. Ja, ok. Irgendwelche muss erlöschen. Aber wenigstens
ist es nicht random, sondern einfach die letzten vier, die angelegt werden in der Schleife.
Ja, ok. Es ist sinnvoll, es ist wirklich sinnvoll. Also ich muss sagen, ganz im Ernst, ich hab
damit noch nicht so viel gemacht wie mit Terraform, aber mir gefällt das. Vom Ansatz her, dass
es eine vollständige Programmiersprache ist und du da auch mal ifs schleifen machen kannst,
die du vielleicht von irgendeiner internen Config was ziehen kannst, irgendwas API abfragen
kannst, anhand dessen ein if machen kannst und was auch immer. Finde ich ehrlich gesagt
angenehmer als mit Terraform. Ich glaube, ich werde in Zukunft da mehr mit machen. Wir
bauen weiter. Ich hoffe, dass das morgen noch was, oder morgen gleich was wird. Wir bauen
weiter. Wir müssen das ja noch hier einmal komplett ausbauen. Ja, ein paar Application
Server, Load Balancer davor, Zertifikate, DNS und das hier alles mal in Pulumi anlegen.
Also quasi das da, was ich hingeschrieben hab.
Lösch mal eine VMA, ob Pulumi das Diff erkennt und fixt. Das erkennt das ja. Geh ich mal
von aus. Gucken wir mal. Ok, das mit dem löschen hat funktioniert. Also er hat aus 8, hat er
runter skaliert auf 4. Ja, hat funktioniert. Ok, ich lösche mal eine. Weg, weg, alle, please,
laden. Löschen, löschen. So stelle ich mir jetzt aber löschen eigentlich nicht vor,
habe ich gesagt. Legt er das auch wieder US West an, ja? Was genau hat er denn jetzt
bitteschön am löschen nicht verstanden? Achso. Ah. Ich habe eigentlich gedacht, hier
vorne dreht sich das, weil meistens dreht sich das hier vorne, wenn was passiert. Ok,
jetzt ist weg. Gucken wir mal, was Pulumi macht. Also ich predicte, er legt die wieder an und
auch mit US West. Warum nicht? Kacke. Warum nicht? Weil er den lokalen State gecashed hat
oder so. Muss ich ihm sagen, State Refresh? Ich muss hier bestimmt sagen, State Refresh
oder sowas. Ah, Pulumi Refresh ist es. Achso. Ok, das wusste ich nicht, dass man das von
Hand einmal vorher machen muss. Yes. Und jetzt? Jetzt sollte er es checken. Ja, genau. Einer
muss Created werden. Wusste nicht, dass man vorher Refresh von Hand machen muss. Ich dachte,
das macht er. Vielleicht kann man das auch einbauen, irgendwie, dass er sagt, gibt es
vielleicht eine Option, irgendwie Auto-Refresh oder sowas. Will man ja eigentlich nicht.
Man möchte ja nicht unnötig API-Requests die ganze Zeit abfeuern, falls du mal auch
gegen irgendwas gehst, was Geld kostet oder das limitiert oder was auch immer. Ok, Created,
zack und wir haben wieder einen Einser. Gehe ich jetzt mal von aus. Wir haben wieder einen
Einser. Achso, ich kann auch den Refresh-Button drücken. Das kann ich auch machen. Anschaut,
die Seite zu lösen. Guck mal, wir haben einen Einser wieder, der ist auch US-West. Also,
das funktioniert alles. Das Zeug ist wirklich gut. Also, es ist schade, dass zur Zeit, wo
ich noch beim Provider gearbeitet habe, es diese ganzen Tools noch nicht gab. Da war
sehr viel Turnschuh-Admin, manuelle Bash-Skripte, Doku-Wikis, wo drin steht, wo man irgendwas
machen muss und so. Das wäre wirklich enorm hilfreich gewesen.
Also, ich finde das Tool richtig gut. Und mir gefällt es, obwohl ich damit nicht so viel
gemacht habe, mir gefällt das jetzt dadurch, dass es eine ordentliche Programmiersprache
hat, die ich für einen ganz besser, zumindest so erster Eindruck als Terraform. Terraform
ist Pains-Champ. Ist vor allem ewig lang immer alles. Ja, das ist nice. Oh, Jett, mir reicht
es für heute. Anstrengend. Ich weiß nicht, wie manche andere Streamer irgendwie 10 Stunden
oder 24 Stunden streamen. Okay, die labern ja auch nicht die ganze Zeit. Die sitzen dann
da und pennen teilweise. Aber trotzdem, ich weiß nicht, wie manche Leute 8 Stunden am
Tag da durchhalten. 8, 9, 9, 30 Stunden, 10 Stunden am Tag streamen. Geht das überhaupt?
Bin ich zu alt für 38? Geht das nicht mehr? Oh man, alles klar. Jett, ich hoffe, euch
hat der Stream gefallen. Ich muss jetzt ein bisschen MMO criden. 8 Stunden Spiele spielen
ist auch weniger anstrengend, wie was Neues lernen. Ja, ja schon, da ist schon rechts.
Du hast dich influenzeln lassen und einen PC zusammengebaut. Ja, ich hoffe aber auch
ein 5000 Euro PC. Da drunter geht ja nichts mehr hier. Nee, was hast du denn bestellt?
Was hast du bestellt?
Okay, wie sagt er nicht. Alles klar, dann haue ich jetzt ab. Jett, wir sehen uns morgen.
Hoffe ich, dass es was wird. Morgen ist ein Tag vor Weihnachten. Bis denn, macht's gut.
See you.